Scheiße Bernd, es reicht mir. Ich habe dieses Lotterleben satt. Immer dasselbe. Alle lachen mich aus. Niemand erkennt mein Potenzial. Ich meine es ernst, Bernd. Ich habe Waffen hier und ich werde morgen früh an meine frühere Schule gehen und mal so richtig gepflegt grillen. Vielleicht komme ich ja auch davon. Haltet die Ohren offen, Bernds. Ihr werdet morgen von mir hören. Merkt euch nur den Namen des Orts Winnenden. Und jetzt keine Meldung an die Polizei, keine Angst. Ich trolle nur.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 129. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove, wie gewohnt und ich bin immer noch wieder mal auf Reisen. Nach Düsseldorf hat mich die Reise geführt und wenn ich so unterwegs bin, dann versuche ich natürlich auch immer so viele interessante Leute zusammen zu kratzen, wie es nur irgendwie geht, um die Zeit gut zu nutzen. Umso glücklicher bin ich, dass ich die Gelegenheit habe, hier aufzukreuzen, wo ich jetzt gerade bin. Ja, vielleicht fangen wir doch erstmal an mit der Begrüßung, denn der Gast heute ist Udo. Udo Vetter, hallo.
Guten Abend oder guten Tag.
Guten Abend oder guten Tag. Noch ist Tag. Aber der ein oder andere mag es auch. Zum Einschlafen hören wurde mir häufiger gesagt, das sollten wir uns bemühen, nicht ganz so einschläfern zu wirken. Das wird uns, glaube ich, auch bedenken. Selten bin ich mit so einer schwammigen Grundvoraussetzung in so einem Gespräch gegangen, weil es eigentlich so ein bisschen mehr ein Gefühl ist, was sich bei mir auch in der letzten Zeit entwickelt hat aufgrund einiger Ereignisse. Grundsätzlich geht es natürlich um eine Diskussion, die derzeit mal wieder sehr breiten Raum einnimmt, die aber überhaupt nicht neu ist, sondern die einfach schon seit sehr langer Zeit gärt und die immer wieder ganz gerne aus dem Schrank geholt wird, nämlich die Diskussion um das Internet und der Behauptung, dass es sich doch bei dem Internet um einen rechtsfreien Raum handelt oder nicht handeln darf. Das wird immer wieder regelmäßig kolportiert. Das Ganze geht schon lange zurück und ist eigentlich auch von allen Seiten auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise aufgegriffen worden. Ich glaube, wann das so richtig begonnen hat, das wissen wir auch nicht, aber irgendwann in den 90er Jahren kam das Ganze auf. Es gab dann in der Szene so einen schönen kleinen Aufkleber in Form eines Ortseingangsschildes, wo drauf stand globales Dorf, rechtsfreier Raum. Was ja auch, wenn ich selber so zurückdenke, auch ein Stück weit ein Selbstverständnis der Szene dabei war, wenn auch so in ironischer Anspielung. Man hatte auf einmal mit dem Internet so einen Ort gefunden oder sich selber auch erschaffen, in dem es, so schien es zumindest zum Beginn, einerseits sich die ganze Welt tummelte. Es war natürlich nicht die ganze Welt, sondern eben nur ein sehr kleiner Ausriss dieser Welt. Andererseits man aber weitgehend ja ohne Beobachtung auf der einen Seite, aber vor allem auch ohne Reglementierung so seine Diskussionsexperimente starten konnte und so weiter. Und sich diesem ja Recht, Druck entzogen zu wissen, schaffte natürlich dann auf einmal so eine Atmosphäre, die ja sehr schwer zu beschreiben ist. Und ich denke, das ist das, was in diesem kleinen Aufkleber sich so widerspiegelt. Natürlich aber auch die ironische Anspielung, dass es sehr wohl Leute gibt, die eben das ganz anders sehen. Das war dann nur schnell zu spüren. Das fing halt irgendwie an, schon so mit dem akribischen Verfolgen der Raubkopierer- Szene. Damals halt weniger noch die audiovisuellen Medien, sondern eigentlich mehr so die erste Software, die umher gereicht wurde. Vielleicht mal jetzt erst mal so zu dir, Udo. Du bist, ja, das ist bekannt, Rechtsanwalt. Strafrecht ist glaube ich dein Schreckenpferd oder Vorredner.
Das ist mein Hauptaufgabengebiet. Ich bin Fachanwalt für Strafrecht, also vorwiegend auf dem Gebiet der Strafverteidigung tätig, aber eben durch viele Entwicklungen auch im Bereich des Internets mit anderen Rechtsgebieten durchaus vertraut, also was Abmahnungen angeht und ähnliche Sachen. Also was Online-Recht angeht, das hat uns in den letzten Jahren doch auch schon stark begleitet hier im Büro.
Aber das war nicht immer so?
Nein, das war nicht immer so. Ich habe angefangen als Allgemeinanwalt 1995, mich selbstständig gemacht, nachdem ich in einer größeren Kanzlei tätig war. Damals gab es hier bei uns im Büro noch kein Internet. Das Internet hat bei uns Einzug erhalten in Form eines 28K-Modems der Deutschen Bank. Die hat das damals gestellt, denn wir wollten online Banking machen und mit der Zeit hat sich dann herausgestellt, dass man mit diesem Ding, das da so piepste, haben damals noch glaube ich analogen ISDN-Telefonen, aber fast noch quasi analog, dass man da mit E-Mails und sowas verschicken kann. Ich glaube, ich habe dann zwei Jahre später gemerkt, dass man nicht nur E-Mails verschicken kann, sondern auch Anlagen beifügen kann in Form von Dateien. Und so, ich schätze mal, im Bereich Jahr 2000, 2001 haben wir dann auch zur Kenntnis genommen, dass es das Internet gibt. Also praktisch so in der Halbzeit sind wir dann eingestiegen und so richtig warm geworden mit dem Internet und der Online-Welt bin ich eigentlich, seitdem es dann das LawBlock gegeben hat, mein Webblog, da habe ich dann halt auch sozusagen die Kontakte geknüpft und gemerkt, dass hier, für mich gemerkt, dass sich hier, wie du das ja auch schön dargestellt hast, ein ganz neuer Raum auftut, der ja dann auch in den vergangenen sechs Jahren, das LawBlock stammt, aus dem Jahr 2003, unser Leben doch deutlich verändert hat. Also ins unser Leben, aber ich denke auch, das Leben der allermeisten Menschen.
Du hast also sozusagen vor 1995 noch überhaupt gar keinen Technikbezug im einigen Sinne so gehabt oder hat dich das auch mal schon ein bisschen umgeschrieben?
Also ich gehörte nicht zu denen, die damals mit Composurfer, das glaube ich, Nachrichten rausgeschickt haben, dann somewhere there und dann ganz stolz waren, dass irgendjemand aus New York zurückschrieb, ja ich bin auch hier. Das habe ich nur am Rande mitbekommen bei Freunden und Bekannten. Einer der ersten Mandanten, die ich als Selbstständiger beraten habe, war jemand, der wollte eine Internetmesse veranstalten. Das muss 1995, 1996 gewesen sein, als das Internet aus seiner Geheimtipp-Ecke herauskroch und ein bisschen das Licht der Welt erblickte. Das war damals ein Nerd, aber ein geschäftsüchtiger Nerd und er hat in der Tat dann so eine Internetmesse aufgezogen, so einer kleinen Halle. Das war so eine Stadthalle im niederbergischen Raum und da gab es dann diese Computer zu besichtigen und die Wunderwelt der Modems und ähnliches. Das war so der Einstieg, aber wie gesagt, bis es dann bei uns hier angefangen hat, mussten noch einige Jahre vergehen. Also ich konnte damals, ich kann mich noch deutlich daran erinnern, wie ich bei einem Wohnzimmer gestanden habe, auf diesen grünen Bildschirm geguckt habe und mich fragte, was habe ich jetzt davon, wenn ein Unbekannter aus Amerika schreibt, ja ich bin auch hier, lass uns plaudern. Das war also sozusagen mein erster Einzug in einen Chatraum, der war nicht besonders beeindruckend für mich und das hat dann ja auch Jahre gedauert, bis mir selbst auch klar geworden ist, wie wichtig und wie bedeutend das Internet für unseren Horizont und auch für unser alltägliches Leben ist.
Es erfordert schon ein intensiver Auseinandersetzung damit, um wirklich die Dimensionen zu verstehen auch.
Ja, es gibt da zwei Ebenen. Auf der einen Seite, wenn man sich theoretisch Gedanken darüber macht, merkt man, dass das Internet, so wie wir es heute kennen, ja eigentlich, das muss man auch mal sehen, ein relativ junges Medium ist. Wir haben ja, wenn wir vielleicht von 15, maximal 20 Jahren ausgehen, in denen es existiert, eine Entwicklung gemacht, die von der Geschwindigkeit und der Bedeutung für unser Leben zum Beispiel sicherlich größer ist als damals zum Beispiel, als das Automobil groß geworden ist. Das Automobil hat wesentlich länger gebraucht, um sich in das Leben der Menschen einzuschleichen. Deswegen auf der Theorie... Das Telefon, die Elektrizität, alles viel längere Zeiträume. Wir erleben deswegen, meine ich persönlich, auf einer theoretischen Ebene einen der größten Umbrüche, die man wahrscheinlich, wenn man später aus historischer Sicht zurück sieht, überhaupt jemals haben wird. Das ist uns vielleicht nicht so bewusst, aber um auf die praktische Ebene zu kommen, man muss sich ja nur fragen, wie hat das Internet den Alltag von jedem Einzelnen und von mir persönlich verändert? Wenn man das mal einfach ein bisschen abklopft, dann merkt man schon, wie gravierend die Auswirkungen geworden sind, sich auswirken und es ist einfach unglaublich, wie sich alles verändert hat. Also das Internet und der Geldautomat sind vielleicht die bahnbrechendsten Erfindungen, an die wir im Alter dann irgendwann mal zurückdenken werden.
So, man sie sozusagen ihre Einführung erlebt hat.
Ja, wenn ich von meinem beruflichen Alltag ausgehe, auch der berufliche Alltag hat sich ja komplett geändert, was zum Beispiel das Wissensmanagement angeht. Wir sitzen in einem Besprechungsraum, in dem gibt es ein Buchregal, von dem ich zu meiner Schande gestehen muss, das ist in den ersten sieben, acht Jahren meiner Kanzlei Anwaltszätigkeit wesentlich intensiver aufgefüllt worden, als in den letzten fünf oder sechs Jahren. Also alle Werke, die da hoffentlich möglichst staubfrei stehen, sind eigentlich schon veraltet, denn wir kaufen keine Bücher mehr oder höchstens ein oder zwei mal im Jahr, wenn es denn wirklich extreme Fachliteratur sein muss, die online nicht verfügbar ist. Alles andere läuft über Datenbanken, über Online-Dienste und das gesamte Wissensmanagement ist also in elektronischer Form, findet heute statt. Und auch zum Beispiel, nächstes Kapitel, die gesamte Kommunikation, das brauche ich ja nicht weiter auszuführen. Früher war es so, da gab es die Tagespost und dann kamen irgendwann mal die wichtigen Faxe. Heute hat E-Mail und Online-Kommunikation den beruflichen Alltag komplett umgewälzt. Also die Zahl der persönlichen Besprechungen zum Beispiel ist unglaublich rückläufig, einfach weil die allermeisten Mandate auf elektronische Art und Weise abgewickelt werden. Ich erlebe mitunter, das finde ich ganz erstaunlich, dann auch Mandanten, die also schon gar keine Telefonnummer mehr angeben, weil sie sowieso davon ausgehen, dass man nur per Mail kommuniziert. Und der nächste Schritt wird dann wahrscheinlich irgendeine Form des Onlineschreibens sein. Und irgendwann werden wir dann zurückkommen und sagen, wieso sprechen wir eigentlich nicht mehr persönlich miteinander? Aber das sind alles Beispiele, die zeigen, wie gravierend das auch hier auf dem beruflichen Alltag sich auswirkt. Und die Anwaltszertigkeit hat sich also auch extrem verändert in diesen Jahren, was die Abläufe angeht. Und sie hat sich natürlich auch, was die Kommunikation angeht, zum Beispiel mit den Kunden, aber auch mit Behörden teilweise, stark vereinfacht. Man kann also wesentlich rationeller arbeiten, also um einen positiven Aspekt des möglicherweise als böse angesehenen Internets zu sehen. Es wäre heute nicht mehr möglich, mit den personellen und finanziellen Ressourcen das zu machen, wenn es diesen technischen Fortschritt nicht gegeben hätte. Ja, natürlich.
Geht es ja auch nicht sehr viel anders.
Also ich kann unabhängig von politischen Fragen oder ähnlichen, ich muss sagen, ich kann mich da gerne wiederholen. Man muss sich klar darüber machen, dass wir offensichtlich in einer Zeit des extremen Umbruchs leben, was also letztlich im Kern auf das Internet beziehungsweise die Möglichkeit der Online-Kommunikation zurückzuführen ist.
Und trifft der Begriff Informationsgesellschaft da ausreichend?
Ist es das schon? Ja, das ist ja eigentlich keine Informationsgesellschaft. Das hat so etwas Akademisches an sich. Ich denke, es geht schon eher in Richtung Kommunikationsgesellschaft beziehungsweise in den Bereich, dass eben Kommunikation nicht nur grenzenlos möglich ist, sondern auch in grenzenloser Vielfalt möglich ist. Also es ist ja auch die Wahl der Mittel, wie man miteinander kommuniziert, hat sich enorm verändert. Also wenn wir vor fünf oder sechs Jahren noch E-Mail als den Stein der Weisen angesehen haben, dann erleben wir heute, wie zum Beispiel durch solche Dinge wie Twitter, die ja unglaublich belächelt werden, dass es noch andere Möglichkeiten gibt und dass der Fortschritt eben noch nicht zum Stillstand gekommen ist, sondern dass wir eigentlich erst am Anfang stehen. Also gerade was das Beispiel Twitter angeht, werden wir sicherlich, dass dieses unterschätzte Medium oder dieses unterschätzte Mittel zur Kommunikation bald erleben, dass das in Firmen einen Zug hält. Das sind alles Dinge, die noch ganz ganz wahnbrechend viel mehr verändern werden, als wir heute vielleicht erkannt haben. Also ob man es Informations- oder Kommunikations-
bescheidenen beschreibt. Also Twitter sozusagen als Dienst, Microblogging, nicht konkret jetzt Twitter selbst, der Dienst, sondern diese Kommunikationsform.
Also nicht Twitter als Dienst, aber Twitter als Idee. Microblogging im Sinne eines Kommunikationstools, das von seiner bestechenden Einfachheit her die Möglichkeit eröffnet, unglaublich viele Dinge zu machen. Ich bin nun nicht in ein großes Unternehmen eingebunden. Ich muss nicht so viel mit Vorgesetzten und Kollegen kommunizieren, aber ich denke, wenn diese Idee mal aufgegriffen wird, wird die auch wieder revolutionär und umwälzend sein, was die Firmenkommunikation angeht. Und das sind alles Schritte, die in sehr kurzer Abfolge erfolgen und die uns schon nachdenklich stimmen sollten. Aber ich meine nicht pessimistisch, sondern durchaus optimistisch, denn das sind ja alles Sachen, die unser Leben nicht nur vereinfachen, sondern wie ich durchaus finde auch schöner machen. Also wenn ich überlege, zum Beispiel, was die letzten sechs Jahre seitdem ich dieses Blog gegründet habe an positiven Kontakten dazugekommen, ist auch an Kontaktmöglichkeiten, was sich alles letztendlich aus der Online-Welt ergibt, dann muss ich sagen, dann wiegt das für mich persönlich die sicherlich auch vorhandenen negativen Erfahrungen, die man halt immer wieder mit einigen verrückten, sage ich mal vorsichtig, vielleicht können wir da noch in Details gehen, macht bei weitem auf.
Was sind denn die positiven Auswirkungen, bevor wir auf die negativen kommen?
Die positiven Auswirkungen ist erstmal, dass die Online-Welt einem eben neue Kommunikationskanäle ermöglicht und dass sie einem eben entgegen der weit verbreiteten Ansicht nicht einsamer macht oder auch nicht singulärer in der Welt sein lässt. Ich habe eher das Gefühl, das Gegenteil ist der Fall, dass man gerade dadurch, dass man eben Grenzen wie den Raum jetzt, also die räumliche Distanz, besser überwinden kann als über das Telefon, mit diesen vielfältigen Möglichkeiten auch wesentlich mehr berufliche oder soziale Kontakte schließen kann, als sie jetzt im realen Leben möglich sind. Also ich will mal ein Beispiel nennen, die weitaus meisten Leute, die zum Beispiel in unsere Kanzlei kommen, das mache ich nicht ich, aber das macht vorwiegend meine Kollegen, aber ich kriege halt immer mit, wenn die Anfragen kommen, die zum Beispiel heiraten wollen heutzutage, die über Eheverträge nachdenken, die haben sich nicht im realen Leben kennengelernt, sondern die haben sich irgendwo im Netz kennengelernt, sei es jetzt in der kommerziellen Partnerbörse, in Chaträumen oder möglicherweise im Umfeld von Webblogs, von Twitter, von was auch immer. Also da zu sagen, die Online-Welt macht einsam oder in der großen Online-Welt ist jeder so ein Streichholz, das ganz einsam im Winde brennt, das ist sehr vermessen und das kann eigentlich auch nur von Menschen kommen, die nicht wissen, welche Möglichkeiten es gibt oder die nicht bereit sind, diese Möglichkeiten mal ohne Vorurteile zu testen.
Denkst du denn, dass es in Deutschland so eine besondere Neophobie gibt? So ein bisschen so, also gerade wenn ich das so, immer ein bisschen schwer solche Vergleiche zu ziehen, aber wenn ich mir zum Beispiel anschaue, wie die Amerikaner halt mit Technologie umgehen, dann sehe ich halt immer schnell, wenn man denen sagt, hier, hör mir mal zu, hier ist was Neues, dann ist so die erste Frage, was kann ich damit machen? So und hier höre ich eigentlich immer als erstes, wozu brauche ich nicht, wozu brauche ich denn das?
Ja, ist doch nur belanglos oder was bringt mir das?
Dann kommt aber auch gleich so eine Diskussion aus, was das für schlimme Auswirkungen haben kann.
Also ich glaube, wir haben da inzwischen auch einen großen Kluft zwischen der veröffentlichten Meinung und der tatsächlichen Meinung, also innerhalb der Generation. Ich glaube, dass die Menschen, die vielleicht bis zum Alter 35 bis 40 vieles von dem auch nicht mehr verstehen, was in der veröffentlichten Presse zum Beispiel über das Internet oder über die Online-Welt oder über Videospiele oder ähnliches dargestellt wird, dass sie das nicht mehr nachvollziehen können, weil die schon einer anderen Generation angehören, die eben genauso wie du das für die Amerikaner geschildert hast, einen viel unbefangeneren Zugang dazu haben, auch einen ideologiefreien Zugang. Die sind damit aufgewachsen, für die ist das Notebook oder für die ist ein Weblog oder Twitter oder die Chat-Räume oder Videospiele. Das sind Dinge, die können sie für den Beruf brauchen, also fürs Lernen, fürs Arbeiten oder auch eben für die Freizeit, also zur Weiterbildung oder zur Unterhaltung. Und die verstehen das nicht, was da drin steht. Ich glaube, dass wir, was wir im Moment erleben, diese Skepsis, die gerade dem Internet gegenübergebracht wird, darauf beruht, dass man lange Jahre einfach verschlafen hat, welche Bewegung und welches Potenzial sich hieraus ergibt. Das ist in politischen Kreisen, aber auch in den Kreisen der Medien nicht angekommen. Und was wir heute erleben über Debatten, über die wir gleich sicherlich noch sprechen werden, ist, dass hier eine gewisse Panikreaktion erfolgt. Und Panikreaktion bedeutet, das ist etwas Bedrohliches für uns. Wir erkennen, da braut sich etwas zusammen, was etablierte Strukturen aufbrechen kann. Etwas, was wir nicht verstehen. Und die natürliche Reaktion des Bedrohten bzw. des Verständnislosen ist natürlich, dann das zu demonisieren und zu sagen, das kann ja nicht sein, denn es ist etwas Neues, was ich nicht verstehe. Es ist etwas Böses, weil es eben nicht den Status quo fortsetzt, also nicht im politischen Sinne, aber im gesellschaftlichen Sinne nicht konservativ ist, sondern es verändert sich was. Und wenn man etwas nicht versteht, dann ist natürlich die natürliche Abwehrreaktion zu sagen, das ist böse. Also wir stellen es in die Ecke, aber ich denke, um das kurz zu sagen, diese Panikreaktion kommt zu spät und diese Panikreaktion kann, auch wenn es natürlich da noch intensive Kämpfe geben wird, auch keinen Erfolg haben. Denn dafür ist der Zug zu sehr abgefahren.
Also richtig neu ist die Debatte ja nicht.
Nein.
Gerade dieser Begriff rechtsfreier Raum, der tummelt sich jetzt irgendwie auch schon seit 15 Jahren so in der Gesellschaft herum. Jetzt kriegt er halt gerade nochmal neue Popularität.
Ja, aber nicht nur Popularität, sondern die Diskussion nimmt jetzt natürlich schon konkretere Züge an. Vor zehn Jahren oder acht Jahren wurde die Diskussion vielleicht auch geführt, aber da wurde sie nicht in so einem gesamtgesellschaftlichen Kontext geführt, nach dem Motto, das Internet kann ja uns alle bedrohen, das Internet ist die Böse, die dunkle Seite der Macht sozusagen, die auf uns zurollt. Das hat ja heute eine ganz andere Dimension. Es gibt ja keinen Politiker, der nicht reflexmäßig heute erst mal auf das Internet schimpft. Das wird ja offensichtlich zu einem tragenden und beherrschenden Thema nicht nur für die Bundestagswahl, sondern auch für die nächste politische Zukunft. Also wir haben da, denke ich, von meinem persönlichen Empfinden, ist die Debatte auf eine ganz andere Ebene hochgeschoben worden. Vielleicht auch nicht ganz unabsichtlich. Aber ich habe, ich wiederhole mich da nach wie vor, das Gefühl, es ist im Moment eine extreme Panikreaktion im Gange, die sich aus Unverständnis und auch aus Angst speist. Das zeigt ja auch dieser extreme Spagat, der heute stattfindet. Wenn also im Iran oder in China getwittert wird für die Freiheit und Gegenunterdrückung, dann ist das etwas Großartiges. Dann ist das etwas, wo man uneingeschränkt applaudiert und sagt, das ist ganz toll, wo auch die Medien keine Probleme damit haben, dann zu zitieren und zu sagen, wir haben das aus Twitter, wir haben das aus YouTube, da haben das mutige Menschen, haben das ins Internet gestellt. Und auf der anderen Seite, bei uns eine Debatte geführt wird, ist die Jugend insgesamt internetsüchtig? Also müssen wir, um das Vehikel des Jugendschutzes vorzuschieben, nicht das Internet schon zum Schutz der Kinder und Jugendlichen regulieren? Oder sind auch nicht die Erwachsenen bedroht durch Hassseiten, also Hate-Sites, die jetzt in die Diskussion kommen? Also es wird ein Bedrohungsszenario aufgebaut und das ist so ein Zwiespalt, der letztendlich wenig verständlich ist, weil man, das ist zumindest meine Erfahrung mit dem Internet, ja eigentlich nicht behaupten kann, dass die größten Teile des Internets per se böse oder bedrohlich sind. Natürlich gibt es überall Schattenseiten, aber die werden natürlich jetzt extrem in den Vordergrund gerückt.
Was für Schattenseiten hast du denn bisher ausmachen können? Ich meine, du hast ja schon angedeutet, so auch als Betreiber eines Blogs hat man zu leiden unter negativen Folgen?
Also als Betreiber des Lawblogs habe ich eigentlich relativ wenig unter negativen Folgen zu leiden gehabt. Ich habe also bis heute keine Gerichtsverfahren um die Seite führen müssen. Ich habe auch keine förmliche Abmahnung erhalten. Es gab natürlich immer mal wieder Leute...
Wer mahnt denn schon einen Anwalt ab?
Ach, da gibt es sicherlich genug Anwälte, die das machen würden, aber es liegt vielleicht auch daran, wenn man sich damit auskennt, dass man dann auch so formuliert, dass einem möglichst wenig Leute an den Karren fahren können. Ich kann ja auch anderen erklären, wie man es am besten schreibt. Man hat natürlich auch das Gefühl. Es gab einige wenige Fälle, wo ich dann mal etwas nachbessern musste. Es gab dann gerade Berichterstattungen über Lottospielsysteme und ähnliche Leute, die sich schon gewehrt haben. Aber da hat man immer eine Lösung gefunden. Für mich persönlich ging das bisher immer recht glimpflich ab. Vielleicht auch vor dem Hintergrund, dass man eher mit mir spricht, als mich abmahnen. Auf eine Abmahnung würde ich wahrscheinlich auch allergischer reagieren als auf einen Gesprächsversuch. Es gab auch durchaus Fälle, wo ich mich missverständlich ausgedrückt habe. Ich glaube, ich gehöre da nicht zu den Leuten, die stur sind und sagen, ich habe immer recht, sondern ich habe mich auch manchmal als Besserem belehren lassen. Dann wird die Formulierung geändert. Aber leiden müssen natürlich schon viele andere Blogger, die vielleicht auch etwas blauäugig Dinge geschrieben haben, die sie möglicherweise dann nicht belegen können oder die eben das Problem haben, dass sie weder von der juristischen Kenntnis noch von den finanziellen Möglichkeiten her sich wirklich dagegen wehren können. Das ist natürlich auch ein großes Problem für Menschen, die im Internet was schreiben, wenn sie dann eine Abmahnung von einem Anwalt bekommen und 1200 Euro Abmahngebühren geltend gemacht werden. Das ist natürlich für jemanden, der nicht täglich damit befasst ist, immer ein Grund, erst mal in Ohnmacht zu fallen. Vor allem dann, wenn 1200 Euro auch noch viel Geld sind. Dass man in den meisten Fällen da locker von runter kommen kann, wenn man sich anwaltlicher Hilfe bedient oder sich juristisch beraten lässt, ist ein anderes Thema. Aber da ist natürlich in den letzten vielen Jahren, gerade in vielen Jahren, gerade in der Anfangszeit der Webblogs viel passiert, was Abmahnungen betrifft und so weiter. Weil so viele Blogger extrem leiden sehen. Ich habe auch Blogger schon weinen sehen, einfach aus Existenzangst. Aber das Ganze hat sich, nachdem sich dann eben auch durch viele Rückfragen und Aufklärungen, an der ja auch andere Blogger beteiligt waren, wo man mal erklärt hat, was darf man und was darf man nicht. Also in dem Sinne, das Internet ist eben kein rechtsfreier Raum. Wenn ihr ins Internet schreibt, müsst ihr auch damit rechnen, dass die Leute durch Google, über die ihr schreibt, finden, was ihr über sie geschrieben habt. Da kommt ja der Topf immer zum Deckel durch Google. Irgendwann findet der, den man durch den Kakao gezogen hat, ja den Text, wenn er nach sich selber googelt. Und da hat sich viel getan. Ich denke, da ist auch Aufklärung betrieben worden, sodass sich so die Abmahnungen wegen falscher Tatsachen, Behauptungen, übler Nachrede, Verleumdung, Beleidigung in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren doch eingependelt haben. Also diese große Welle, wo Blogger mit Abmahnungen und ähnlichen überzogen worden sind, ist nach meinem Eindruck zumindest vorbei.
Aber es hat sich auch richtig was geändert, oder?
Du meinst jetzt die Forenhaftung?
Ich bin im Einzelnen nicht so... Ich habe nur in Erinnerung, dass die Grösse der Abmahnung, also die finanzielle, irgendwie gedeckt wurde.
Ja gut, das betrifft jetzt nicht die Abmahnungen für Webblogs. Also man muss immer unterscheiden, der Blogger haftet ja sozusagen, oder hat ja Risiken auf zwei Ebenen. Einmal für das, was er selber schreibt und einmal das, was die Kommentatoren in seinem Blog, die Gäste, also ins sogenannte, wie fiel es das ja vorher, Gäste-Buch reinschreiben, als berühmte Gäste-Buch. Und da ist es eben so, dass der Blogger für das, was er selber schreibt, erst mal uneingeschränkt haftet und die Rechtsprechung, das muss man sagen, hat sich deutlich verbessert oder geklärt in Richtung Kommentare. Die sind ja das eigentliche Risiko. Ja, jemand schreibt in meinem Blog etwas gegen einen Prominenten, der das gar nicht gut findet, beleidigt den, setzt den herab oder was auch immer. Da haftet man als Blogbetreiber eben immer erst, wenn man wirklich davon Kenntnis hat, also darauf hingewiesen worden ist. Dann muss man kurzfristig reagieren. Die Gesetzesänderung, die du ansprich, sind jetzt die Abmahnung im gewerblichen Bereich. Also wenn ich auf meinem Blog oder auf meiner Seite MP3-Dateien, aktuelle Hits, Filmausschnitte oder ähnliches zum Download zur Verfügung stelle oder mich halt an Tauschbörsen beteilige, da ist die Abmahnungskosten im Bereich des nicht gewerblichen, also wenn ich damit kein Geld verdiene, auf 50 Euro für die erste Abmahnung reduziert worden. Da gibt es allerdings auch viele Nuancen. Man sollte sich nicht darauf verlassen, dass man im Tauschbörsenbereich oder ähnliches heute Narrenfreiheit hat und dass der erste Fehlschuss sozusagen 50 Euro kostet, sondern da hat der Gesetzgeber mal wieder so gearbeitet, wie man es von ihm kennt. Er wollte was Gutes machen, aber es ist ihm letztendlich nicht gelungen, denn die Mitarbeiter der Abmahnindustrie haben natürlich inzwischen schon wieder Mittel und Wege gefunden, auch das zu umgehen und wieder zu ihren doch exorbitant hohen Forderungen, also im Bereich von 500 bis 1000 Euro, zurückzukehren.
Was sind das so für Umgehungsstrategien, die da gefahren werden?
Naja, es ist ja so, das Gesetz sagt, die Abmahnung darf nur dann maximal 50 Euro kosten, wenn du nicht gewerblich gehandelt hast bzw. nicht kommerziell. Das Problem ist ganz einfach, dass die Rechtsprechung jetzt Gerichte gesagt haben, wenn du zum Beispiel ein aktuelles Musikstück anbietest, also was aus der Hitparade kommt, wo man auch bei iTunes oder iTunes oder im Plattenladen noch Geld dafür bekommt, dann ist das schon kommerziell. Das heißt, dann fällt diese Ausschussklausel im Gesetz weg und dann ist wieder der Weg frei zu den bekannten hohen Streitwerten von bis zu 10.000 Euro pro Musikstück. Also da wird auch noch viel debattiert und gestritten. Man sollte halt nach wie vor, dazu kann ich nur raten, wirklich vorsichtig sein, was man macht, weil sonst sind aufgrund der doch durchgängigen Überwachung der Tauschbörsen, gerade durch die Musikindustrie, da gibt es ja richtige Unternehmen, die die Tauschbörsen Tag und Nacht überwachen, muss man einfach damit rechnen, dass man Post vom Anwalt bekommt. Und selbst wenn, lasst mich das nur einen Satz sagen, selbst wenn dein Anwalt die Abmahnung abbügeln kann und es schafft, dass du nichts bezahlen musst, auf deinen eigenen Anwaltskosten, also die Kosten, die du für deinen Rechtsvertreter brauchst, damit er dich raushaut, auf denen wirst du auf jeden Fall sitzen bleiben. Also es ist immer mitunter auch durchaus ein kostspieliges Unterfangen.
Auf jeden Fall nicht sehr rechtsfrei an der Stelle, ist auf jeden Fall schon mal sehr offensichtlich. Jetzt hast du gesagt, Änderung der Rechtsprechung. Auf der einen Seite gibt es die Gesetze, auf der anderen Seite gibt es die juristische Praxis, wie sie sich dann bei einem Richter dann auch konkret entfaltet. Inwieweit ist denn da jetzt eine, wie manifestiert sich diese Änderung? Ist die durch Gesetzesänderung ausgelöst worden oder ist das zunächst einmal ein Lernprozess, der jetzt auch in der juristischen Szene stattfindet? Also ist sozusagen die, wie nennt man denn diese Szene, hat die einen Namen?
Der richtige Paragraphenreiter würde wahrscheinlich Rechtswesen sagen oder Justizwesen, das Rechtswesen. Sehr schön, die Paragraphenreiter. Ja, genau.
Also ist es erforderlich gewesen, dass Gesetze überhaupt erst mal angefasst werden oder wie geht der der Weg? Ist es quasi die Realität in der Rechtsprechung, der Auslegung, die letzten Endes die Gesetze beeinflusst oder muss schon vom Gesetzgeber her etwas angestoßen werden, bevor sich bei den Richtern was erinnert?
Also gerade was das Internet angeht, haben wir auch im juristischen Bereich natürlich Neuland betreten. Es gab, als das Internet groß geworden ist, keine Gesetze für das Internet. Also was ist ein Internetprovider, wer ist ein Contentanbieter, wer ist ein Accessprovider, also ein Zugangsanbieter. Diese Regelungen gab es alles nicht, die mussten dann erst eingeführt werden. Das Problem war eben, das muss man ganz realistisch sehen, dass die Leute, die dann mit dem Internet konfrontiert wurden, auf juristischer Ebene, das Internet sehr wenig kannten. Und dann sind natürlich auch Gesetze erlassen wie das frühere Telemediengesetz und Ähnliches, die nicht sehr praxisnah gewesen sind. Wir haben in den letzten 10, 15 Jahren in diesen Telemediengesetzen in seinen unterschiedlichsten Ausprägungen, das Tele-Dienste-Gesetz hieß es auch mal, wahnsinnig viele Gesetzesänderungen erlebt, einfach weil die immer der Realität angepasst werden mussten. Die Betrachtung der Juristen auf das Internet war immer von außen. Wir haben gesehen, da gibt es jetzt sowas wie Internet, da kamen Klagen vor Gericht, Unterlassungsklagen wegen Online-Äußerungen und ähnlichen Dingen, haben es aber selbst nicht praktiziert und deswegen ist das jetzt ein relativ schneller, aber doch schmerzhafter Anpassungsprozess gewesen, weil eben die Paragrafen nicht auf die Realität passten und wir erleben das nach wie vor jeden Tag, dass sich da viel verbessert, auch sicherlich aufgrund dessen, dass die Leute, die Gesetze schreiben oder sich mit diesen juristischen Themen dann eben auf gesetzgeberischer Ebene beschäftigen, müssen auch mehr Zugang zum Internet haben. Wir haben also auf der einen Seite eine ständige Veränderung der gesetzlichen Rahmenbedingungen. Ich will jetzt nicht behaupten, dass alles besser wird, aber es wird auf jeden Fall problembewusster und wir haben auf der praktischen Ebene dann natürlich die Gerichte, die immer auf der Basis der aktuellen Gesetze sozusagen dann etwas herauslesen müssen und meine Erfahrung aus 15-jähriger Anwaltstätigkeit ist eigentlich, dass es immer möglich ist, andere Ansichten zu vertreten. Also einer der wichtigsten Sprüche, den ich anhänge, ist zwei Juristen, drei Meinungen. Du kannst aus einem Gesetz alles herauslesen, ja, gerade dann, wenn das Gesetz nicht für diesen konkreten Fall oder diese Fallgruppe zugeschnitten ist. Es geht immer schwarz und es geht immer weiß, ja, der Richter hat immer die Möglichkeit, hü oder hot zu sagen.
Aber ist das Internet so generell eher suspekt oder mittlerweile ist es auch angekommen so in den Sälen?
Wir reden ja jetzt über doch Internet im Mainstream doch schon deutlich mehr als zehn Jahre, vielleicht zwölf, dreizehn Jahre, wo auch Juristen natürlich daran nicht vorbeigekommen sind. Also meine Generation, die zum Beispiel studiert hat, wir gehörten zu Ende der 80er Jahre, wir gehörten zu denen, die dann so selbst gebaute Computer irgendwo gekauft haben. Merla kam, die Start-up-Unternehmer. Also wir haben mit Microsoft DOS, hieß das damals, glaube ich noch, DOS 2.0, MS-DOS 2.0 angefangen und das haben natürlich alle anderen Juristen auch, mehr oder weniger, und die Leute, die heute sozusagen Richter sind, Staatsanwälte sind, Anwälte sind, es werden immer mehr, die auch einen praktischen Zugang zur Online-Welt haben und die Wahrscheinlichkeit auf einen Richter zu treffen, der nicht völlig falsche Fehlurteile trifft, weil er einfach keine Ahnung davon hat. Der sagt, kommt mir nicht mit diesem Internetzeug, da kenne ich mich ja gar nicht aus, und dann sagt er aber notwendig, ich muss darüber entscheiden, dann mache ich das mal so, wie ich es aus der Offline-Welt kenne. Diese Gefahr wird immer kleiner. Ich kann nicht daran erinnern, also teilweise unglaubliche Dinge jetzt, vor ungefähr vier, fünf Jahren hatte ich mit einer Richterin zu tun. Da ging es darum, wer hat mit einem Handy telefoniert. Das Handy wurde mit einer Prepaid-Karte betrieben. Diese Prepaid-Karte wurde dann zweieinhalb Jahre vor diesem fraglichen Datum mal von meinem Mandanten gekauft und auch auf dessen Namen registriert. Es war mir unmöglich, trotz sachlicher Darlegung dieser Richterin klarzumachen, dass der Umstand, dass der das mal gekauft und registriert hat, noch nicht bedeutet, dass er auch mit dem Handy telefoniert hat. Also Prepaid, also kein Vertrag auf dem Flohmarkt weiterverkauft. Es war unmöglich. Sie sind doch der Anschlussinhaber. Wie geht das denn? Wo werden denn da die Gebühren abgebucht? Da wird nichts abgebucht. Das kann man aufladen. Wieso? Bei mir bucht die Telekom jeden Monat ab. Also auf derartige Nullkenntnisse zu stoßen, da muss man sich heute schon sehr viel Mühe geben. Selbst ältere Richter, Oberlandesgerichte, die dann so die letztendlichen Entscheidungen treffen. Teilweise dann Leute, die letztendlich gesehen haben bei ihren Kindern und Verwandten, da kann man was machen. Die haben heutzutage auch schon Notebooks und so was und die können auch mit dem Internet Explorer zumindest ins Internet gehen und sind nicht ganz arglos. Also es verbessert sich Tag für Tag und es wird natürlich in einigen Jahren der Zeitpunkt kommen, wo es dann schon die Ausnahme sein wird, wenn man auf jemanden trifft, der einen völlig ignorant, was das Internet angeht, im juristischen Bereich begegnet. Also es wird von Tag zu Tag besser, wobei ich nicht sagen muss, dass die Gesetze besser werden, aber...
Ja, da wollte ich jetzt gerade noch drauf kommen. Wann setzte denn das ein, dass es Gesetze gab, die einen expliziten Internetbezug hatten, die es quasi zugegeben haben, dass es das tatsächlich gibt?
Also ich will mich jetzt nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster hängen, was die Rechtshistorie angeht, aber Telemedien-Gesetz dürfte Mitte bis Ende der 90er Jahre entstanden sein. Da ging es dann halt um die Access-Provider, Content-Provider. Da sind so die grundlegenden Regelungen getroffen worden. Also hafte zum Beispiel ein Access-Provider, also jetzt jemand, der Internetanschlüsse verkauft, auch für den Inhalt. Da hat man sich an der Deutschen Telekom dann orientiert und gesagt, nee, der Telefonanbieter macht das auch nicht. Also sind die grundlegenden Weichen gestellt worden und seitdem haben wir einen kontinuierlichen Gesetzgebungsprozess, also auch die Medienstaatsverträge, Rundfunkstaatsverträge, das Telemediengesetz und alles Mögliche, was da läuft, das geht immer weiter. Aber rechtsfrei war, dass der Raum Internet nur so lange auf die Nerds beschränkt war. Ja, also so lange niemand, 99,9% der Bevölkerung, nichts damit anfangen konnten. Gesetze gab es dann relativ früh, wobei man ja auch sagen muss, es ist ja auch nicht so, dass die allgemeinen Gesetze, die für uns im Alltag gelten, nicht für das Internet passen würden. Also eBay zum Beispiel, also Shopping im Internet, dafür haben wir das Bürgerliche Gesetzbuch. Das gilt seit weit über 100 Jahren und das taugt in 95% seiner Ausgestaltungen durchaus auch für die Online-Welt.
Das ist ja auch automatisch gültig.
Ist auch gültig, also oder was zum Beispiel eher verletzende Äußerungen im Internet angeht, ja, oder zum Beispiel ganz schlimme Sachen wie Volksverhetzung oder ähnliches. Das Strafgesetzbuch gilt zum Beispiel, was Volksverhetzung angeht, die sogenannten Hassseiten, die jetzt in der Diskussion sind. Das gilt natürlich zweifellos und uneingeschränkt auch für das Internet. Das heißt, wenn ich in Deutschland am Computer sitze und Volksverhetzung betreibe, dann mache ich mich damit im Internet durch das Schreiben genauso strafbar, wie wenn ich die Volksverhetzung in eine rechtsradikale Zeitung reinsetze oder sie ausdrucke und sie an den nächsten Baum hier pinne. Das macht letztendlich juristisch keinen Unterschied, sodass also die Legende vom Internet als rechtsfreier Raum wirklich teilweise aus meiner Sicht im Moment in der aktuellen Diskussion böswillig und auch mutwillig vorgeschoben wird, einfach um das Internet auch zum Boomer für viele Dinge zu machen, für die es eigentlich nichts kann. Also wir haben in jedem Bereich, gerade im Strafrecht, völlig ausreichende Gesetze für das Internet.
Völlig ausreichend. Ich wollte nämlich gerade fragen, ob es eigentlich jetzt aus der anwaltlichen Praxis heraus, das ist ja dein Blickwinkel, ob es denn eigentlich auch Fälle gibt, wo zu wenig auf die spezifischen Eigenschaften des Internets Rücksicht genommen würde und wo es sehr wohl angemessen wäre, das Recht klarzustellen, expliziter zu machen, keine Ahnung, wo man einfach das BGB versagt, also wo es sozusagen wirklich nötig ist, Anpassungen vorzunehmen.
Gibt es sowas?
Jenseits dessen, was schon geregelt ist?
Wir haben vielleicht eher das Problem, dass das Internet ja ein sehr demokratisches Medium ist. Das heißt, ich mache einen Blog auf, einen Webblog oder ich mache eine Internetseite auf oder ich gehe auf Twitter und dort habe ich eine Stimme, die theoretisch von der ganzen Welt gehört werden kann. Das ist ja das Neue am Internet. Wenn ich den richtigen Content liefere, dann habe ich erst mal eine potenziell unbegrenzte Zahl von Publikum und ich bin nicht auf die normalen Medien angewiesen. Da ist es vielleicht so, dass man etwas mehr Rücksicht darauf nehmen müsste, dass natürlich diese Äußerungen, die jetzt zum Beispiel in Webblogs oder auf Twitter oder in Chaträumen im Internet gemacht werden, eben nicht im wirtschaftlichen, kommerziellen Bereich gemacht werden, dass sie häufig aus einer, sag es mal vorsichtig, privaten Arglosigkeit kommen und dass die Leute, die das schreiben, einfach unbedacht handeln. Mein Eindruck ist immer, dass dann, wenn sich jemand zum Beispiel auf den Schlips getreten fühlt, möglicherweise auch zu Recht durch Äußerungen, zum Beispiel im Internet, immer gleich mit der großen Keule vorgegangen wird. Obwohl möglicherweise ein 17-Jähriger das geschrieben hat, der sich einfach mal Luft gemacht hat. Ich rede jetzt nicht von irgendwie so einem Amokdrungen, aber zum Beispiel bei Beleidigungsdelikten gegen Lehrer oder ähnliches. Natürlich kann man immer sagen, das kann die Welt insgesamt lesen, das ist ein Unterschied, als ob es auf dem Pausenhof gesagt wird, aber in der Praxis natürlich liest sowieso nicht die Welt, was ein 17-Jähriger als eine Lehrerin sagt.
Das sei dann in den Quaternigen geklagt und dann hat man den Barbara Streisand-Effekt.
Aber da wird natürlich, die Gesetze sind dann halt teilweise auch dafür gemacht, das sieht man ja in dieser Abmahlungspraxis, da wird dann auch mit Kanonen auf Spatzen geschossen. Da müsste man vielleicht im Sinne dieser 50-Euro-Regelung, die wir vorhin gemacht haben, auch ein bisschen zurückfahren. Wobei das auch nicht wieder ein Internet- Problem ist, sondern auch ein Problem für das Strafrecht insgesamt. Zum Beispiel das Stichwort Ehrenschutz. Wir haben in Deutschland ein unglaublich ausgeprägtes System des Ehrenschutzes. Es ist mir also kaum möglich, etwas Kritisches zu sagen über eine Person, die mir nicht gefällt, ohne dass diese Person sich möglicherweise subjektiv direkt beleidigt fühlt und ruft Straftat, Staatsanwalt, Gericht, Strafe. Da sollten wir uns, meine ich persönlich, vielleicht eher ein Beispiel an den USA nehmen, wo eben die freie Rede auch höher geschätzt wird. Es gibt eigentlich keinen Grund dafür, für jeden Pups im Internet, wo jemand mal über einen anderen herzieht, direkt die Zivilgerichte und den Staatsanwalt zu bemühen. Da müsste auch mehr Freiheit herrschen nach dem Motto, es muss auch mal Klartext geredet werden können, ohne dass es gleich Geld strafen oder was auch immer hagelt. Weil natürlich eine Großteil der Überlastung der Justiz, die ja immer sehr beklagt wird, von solchen Bagatellfällen ausgeht. Also man kann schon sagen, dass aus meiner Erfahrung mit solchen Internetdelikten die Deutschen sind halt auch dann leicht ein Volk der beleidigten Leberwürste. Solange ich was im Internet schreibe über andere, da ist das alles kein Problem. Aber wer einer antwortet auf meine Angriffe und vergreift sich auch nur ansatzweise im Ton, dann muss ich direkt Strafanzeige machen, Anwaltbeauftragung, Unterlassungserklärung. Da müsste der Gesetzgeber vielleicht mal sagen, sowas geht nur für Ehrverletzungen von einigem Gewicht. Heute ist es durchaus schon möglich, dass man wegen jeder kleinsten Äußerung, die also den anderen stören kann, vor Gericht gezogen werden kann, ob man letztendlich damit durchkommt oder nicht, ist wieder eine andere Frage. Also da müsste viel gemacht werden. Du hörst das aus meinen Worten, es ist eigentlich das Gegenteil, das Internet ist nicht der rechtsfreie Raum. Das Internet ist nur aus Sicht derjenigen ein rechtsfreier Raum, die es entweder nicht kennen oder die es nicht verstanden haben. Das Internet ist, würde ich sagen, im Gegenteil ein außerordentlich kontrollierter Raum. Nimm mal zum Beispiel private Geschäfte auf eBay oder Leute, die sich mit 18, 20 Jahren sagen, komm ich mache mich mit einem eBay-Shop selbstständig. Ich erlebe das immer wieder hier in unserer Praxis, das dauert keine zwei Monate, dann geben die heulend auf und mit einem Minus von etlichen tausend Euro, weil das erste, was einem heute passiert, wenn man einen kleinen eBay-Shop aufmacht und versucht, mal was dazu zu verdienen oder vielleicht sich sogar seine Existenz damit zu verdienen, ist, dass nach spätestens einer Woche der Briefkasten voll ist mit Abmahnungen, weil man in der Widerrufsbelehrung ein Komma vergessen hat, weil man in der Widerrufsbelehrung nicht reingeschrieben hat, wo der Gerichtsstand ist. Ja, also ich übertreibe jetzt ein bisschen, aber das läuft letztendlich darauf hinaus, also selbstverständliche Dinge.
Also so wie auch mit Impressum, also formale Fehler sozusagen.
Der junge Existenzgründer vergisst in seinem Impressum, die Umsatzsteueridentifikationsnummer anzugeben. Würde man ja sagen, interessiert den normalen Kunden herzlich wenig, aber das ist abmahnfähig. Oder ich hatte zum Beispiel den Fall, da schüttelt man auch den Kopf, junger Mann, junge Frau gründet einen Shop für Reizubehör, ganz auf kleiner Basis. Sie schrieb dann in die Widerrufsbelehrung, sie haben die Möglichkeit, diesen Vertrag innerhalb von 14 Tagen zu widerrufen. Das Gesetz spricht von zwei Wochen. Der Unterschied wird dann praktisch, wenn die Frist an einem Feiertag endet oder an einem Sonntag, weil dann bei zwei Wochen, im juristischen Sinne, endet die Woche erst am Montag. Aber bei 14 Tagen natürlich nicht, da endet die am Sonntag. Du siehst das Internet als rechtsfreier Raum, das würde ich mal in den Bereich der Legenden verweisen, in jedem Punkt. Also auch in anderen Bereichen, was gerade zum Beispiel Tauschbörsen angeht. Wir haben ja heutzutage, wissen vielleicht viele nicht, die sogenannte anlassunabhängige Internetüberwachung, die sitzt beim Bundeskriminalamt, die sitzt auch in den Landeskriminalämtern, da sitzen, das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Ich glaube, beim Bundeskriminalamt, rund um die Uhr, 20 Polizisten, ausgebildete Leute, die eigentlich nichts machen, als das, was wir auch sonst gerne machen, nämlich im Internet surfen und zu gucken, wo gibt es denn Ansatzpunkte für Straftaten? Also die warten nicht auf eine Anzeige, sondern die gucken. Streife. Die Streife im Internet.
Da ist ja erst mal so nichts gegen einen zu sagen.
Und die gibt es bei den Landeskriminalämtern auch. Und das wird ja ausgebaut, das wird ja diskutiert, also auch noch den Jugendschutz da anzugliedern und Sozialarbeiter und alles Mögliche. Ja, so eine zentrale Internetagentur, die erst mal alle Seiten sozusagen auf ihre Jugendschutzkompatibilität überprüft, zu gründen. Also da zu sagen, es wäre ein Rechtsreierraum ist einfach illusorisch. Und so groß ist das deutsche Internet auch nicht, wenn man mal überlegt, wie viel 20 Leute rund um die Uhr zum Beispiel sich anschauen können, dass man sagen kann, das ist nicht unter Kontrolle. Abgesehen davon, dass natürlich es auch die Möglichkeit gibt, ja heutzutage schon online Strafanzeigen zu erstatten. Da wird ja jedem, jeder Strafanzeige wird nachgegangen. Es wird zumindest überprüft, ist da was dran. Also auch die andersunabhängige Kontrolle ist also schon relativ groß. Ja natürlich, klar. Es gibt ja keine Stadt, wo die Menschen nicht darüber klagen, dass sie schon lange keinen Polizisten mehr gesehen haben, der zu Fuß geht. Also wenn man doch mal sieht, dann fährt irgendwo mal ein Streifenwagen vorbei, der aber auch auf dem Weg zum Einsatz ist. Aber der Polizist als Ansprechpartner sozusagen, der fehlt ja im realen Leben. Das ist ja die weit verbreitete Klage. Im Internet ist das nach meinem Eindruck nicht so. Also wenn man jetzt noch einen Schritt weitergeht, gerade was die Tauschbörsen angeht, ja, man muss sich darüber klarmachen, da sind es nicht nur Leute, die dann so surfen und gucken, sondern die Tauschbörsen werden also auch von den Polizeibehörden routinemäßig mit Programmen gescannt. Da gibt es spezielle Programme dafür, die kann man also konfigurieren, was für Inhalte man sucht, was für Dateien man sucht. Und die scannen das regelrecht und werfen dann halt auch Positivbefunde aus. Ja, das ist ein vollautomatisiertes Verfahren. Also man kann sagen, natürlich wird im Bereich dessen geguckt, was strafbar ist. Also entweder zum Beispiel Volksverhetzung und das andere Thema, was ja auch den strafbare Internetinhalt schlechthin ist, eben die Kinderpornografie, also der dokumentierte Missbrauch von Kindern auf Filme oder Fotos. Wenn man so was heutzutage ins Netz stellt, dann ist es nicht so, dass man da sagen kann, ach ja, das Internet, rechtsfreier Raum, da bin ich anonym, sondern man kann davon ausgehen, wenn man so was in eine Tauschbeuse reinstellt, dass man auch aufliegt damit.
Ist man nicht eigentlich auch im Internet noch sehr viel auffindbarer als im echten Leben?
Natürlich. Im echten Leben ist es ja so, dass man zumindest identifiziert werden muss, wie auch immer. Im Internet hat man ja sozusagen sein Autokennzeichen auf der Datenautobahn immer bei sich, nämlich die IP-Adresse. Die lässt natürlich keinen unmittelbaren Rückschluss auf die Person zu, die am Computer gesessen hat. Aber die IP-Adresse ist natürlich ein Merkmal, das immer den Ermittlungsansatz liefert. Natürlich schlecht für Leute, die ihr WLAN offen lassen oder die es größeren Gruppen, sei es jetzt freiwillig oder durch Unachtsamkeit, weil sie es schlecht verschlüsseln, zur Verfügung stellen. Wenn dann darüber Mist gemacht wird, ist immer der Anschlussinhaber, dessen IP-Adresse festgestellt worden ist, das Opfer in Anführungsstrichen, weil der kriegt die Hausdurchsuchung. Also die IP-Adresse ist, man muss sich gleich darüber sein, wenn man ins Internet geht mit seiner eigenen IP-Adresse und damit wird Schindluder getrieben oder man macht den Schindluder selber, dann ist es ebenso, die IP-Adresse ist das Nummernschild und die ist relativ sicher zu dokumentieren.
Es hast ja gesagt, okay, im Internet gibt es irgendwie, das Recht trifft nicht nur sowieso schon zu, sondern darüber hinaus gibt es auch noch mal Gesetze, die explizit darauf schauen und alles befindet sich unter besonderer Beobachtung. Andererseits meintest du, das überlastet auch den Apparat, also den juristischen Apparat, dadurch, dass einfach auch unzählige neue Bagatellfälle aufkommen. Nun gibt es ja auch im Internet eine eigene Regel Kultur. Also wenn man jetzt mal das Internet sozusagen mal weniger als als technischer Bereich, technischen Bereich anschaut, sondern mehr so als Kulturraum, da gab es zumindest zum Anfang ein großes Maß an Selbstregulierung in jeder Hinsicht und zwar sowohl was jetzt die technischen Standards betraf, da basierte viel auf gegenseitigen Vertrauen und allgemeinem Einvernehmen, auch so in dem Ausbildungsprozess dessen, also Stichwort so Request for Comments und ähnliche Sachen, aber noch sehr viel mehr eben auch so dieses Verhalten. Die Netiquette des Markets mag jetzt auch so ein Phänomen vor allem der westlichen Gesellschaften sein. Andere Bereiche der Welt mögen im Internet anders umgehen, aber trotzdem gab es solche Sachen. Siehst du denn generell eigentlich auch den Ansatz als Möglichkeit, dass man sagt, man muss im Internet spezifisch auch sehr viel mehr auf diese Selbstregulierung setzen. Man darf da die Dinge nicht so heiß essen, wie sie gekocht werden, so ganz salopp gesagt. Ist das ein Ansatz, ist das vielleicht auch ein Experimentierfeld für ein anderen Umgang mit Recht und mit einem anderen Umgang miteinander?
Ja, es ist wie im wirklichen Leben. Letztendlich ist es aus meiner Sicht eine Erziehungsfrage, wenn wir jetzt vielleicht nicht von unserer Generation ausgehen, die in das Internet reingewachsen ist, sondern mal von den Leuten, die heute in die Grundschule gehen, von den Kindern, sollen ja schon nach neuen Studien die Vierjährigen auch im Internet unterwegs sein, wo auch immer. Wenn man bei diesem ansetzt, da sieht man ja, wie ich meine, zwei große Probleme, was unsere heutige Pädagogik angeht. Es ist für mich zum Beispiel persönlich heutzutage immer noch unverständlich, wieso man 13 Jahre zur Schule gehen kann, ohne mal irgendetwas über Kindererziehung gelernt zu haben, obwohl die meisten später Kinder bekommen werden. Und es ist auch mein Eindruck, dass die Schulen heute onlinefeindlich sind nach wie vor. Es gibt also zum Beispiel in dem Gymnasium, wo mein Patenkind hingeht, das Mädchen ist 12 Jahre alt, kennt aus dem Büro, aus ihrem Elternhaus Eltern, die internetaffin sind, die den ganzen Tag am Computer arbeiten, kann das natürlich auch selber schon. Und in ihrer Schule gibt es ja nur den altbekannten Computerraum, der die meiste Zeit abgeschlossen ist. Und wenn er mal auf ist, stehen da Computer, die also so jenseits von der zulässigen Altersgrenze sind, mit denen man gar nichts machen kann. Also, nach meiner Ansicht ist das, um deine Frage aufzugreifen, diese Internetkultur, die auf Rücksichtnahme und Anstand und vielleicht auch die Fähigkeit mal zu sagen, ok, habe ich Unrecht gehabt, begraben wir diesen Streit, beruht, das ist letztendlich genau wie im wirklichen Leben eine Erziehungsfrage. Also das, was Politiker oder Soziologen als Medienkompetenz bezeichnen. Und da ist mein persönlicher Eindruck, da wird zu wenig für gemacht. Gerade weil eben auch die heutige Lehrergeneration, zumindest soweit ich sie kenne, sind ja Leute in meinem Alter oder vielleicht zehn Jahre älter, eben selbst keinen Zugang dazu hat und es möglichst diese Vermittlung von Medienkompetenz aus dem Weg geht. Wenn man das machen würde in der Schule, also zum Beispiel Online-Kompetenz, wo sind die Risiken im Internet, welchen Sachen muss ich aus dem Weg gehen, wie verhalte ich mich zum Beispiel in den Chat räumen oder sowas. Das wäre ja mal lebensnah Unterricht, wie die Kinder. Wenn so was gemacht werden könnte, würde ich da in einer Utopie durchaus Chancen einräumen. Nur, ich meine, heute ist es eben so, dass die Kinder und Jugendlichen selber noch ins kalte Wasser geschubst werden. Ich glaube, dass die meisten Zwölfjährigen heute mehr Internetkompetenz sich selbst angeeignet haben, als sie zum Beispiel von ihren Lehrern vermittelt bekommen haben oder ihre Lehrer selbst besitzen. Und dann ist es natürlich so, die Welt im Internet ist letztendlich immer dann, logischerweise, wenn diese Kompetenz nicht vermittelt wird, erfolgreich vermittelt wird, genauso rau wie das reale Leben. Das heißt, wir haben im realen Leben Leute, die sich nicht an Regeln halten, sei es jetzt zivilrechtlich oder strafrechtliche oder gesellschaftliche Regeln, Konventionen, und die werden wir auch im Internet weiter haben. Und deswegen meine Befürchtung, wenn man das reale Leben anguckt, wird der Umgangston der Menschen miteinander ja auch nicht unbedingt sozialer und freundlicher, ja. Das beschränkt sich ja nicht mehr nur auf die Großstädte. Ich glaube nicht, dass man im Internet auf diese Art und Weise dann weiter kommen wird. Also die Hoffnung, dass man irgendwann mal ohne das BKA im Internet oder ohne Abmahnung und ähnliches auskommen wird, halte ich für relativ utopisch, um das mal zusammenzufassen. Da müsste viel früher eingesetzt werden.
Na gut, ich meine, Utopien sind ja jetzt erst mal nicht schlecht, das kann man auch übernachten. Ich meine, es gibt ja auch so dieses Konzept, das kenne ich mal wieder, die Fachbegriffe nicht, also so eine Schlichtung.
Mediation, ja, zum Beispiel.
Nun sind das ja auch alles Mittel und Wege, die vor allem für die Kommunikation voraussetzen und da haben wir natürlich jetzt im Netz auch einen schlagenden Vorteil, dass dort Kommunikation ja sich ganz gut automatisieren lässt oder zumindest niedrigschwellig auch an die Leute heranführen lässt. Wäre das...
Grundsätzlich ist es immer ein wichtiger Gedanke, dass Schlichtung und Mediation sind ja auch etwas, was gerade im juristischen Bereich, um darauf zurückzukommen, groß im Kommen sind, aber die halt auch in der Praxis ihre Grenzen haben. Es gibt ja inzwischen sogar, kann ich ja vielleicht mal einfließen lassen, Gerichte, die Mediation anbieten. Also es ist dann so, wenn jemand klagt, dann kann es sein, dass der Richter zurückschreibt, versucht euch doch mal erst mal über einen Mediator zu einigen. Es gibt da so Modellprojekte, also es ist nicht so, dass die Justiz solchen Dingen nicht aufgeschlossen gegenübersteht. Nur meine bescheidene Erfahrung mit derartigen Dingen, weil ich häufig nicht damit zu tun habe als Strafverteidiger, ist, da sind, der Mediation, sind natürlich Grenzen gesetzt. Mediation und miteinander kommunizieren setzt ja immer voraus, dass beide Seiten willig sind. Und aus meiner Erfahrung ist es bei heutigen Konflikten im juristischen Bereich sehr häufig so, dass irgendwo die, mindestens eine der Parteien aufgegeben hat, kommunikationsbereit zu sein und man da keinen Exzess, also kein Zugang mehr zu diesen Menschen findet. Und fast genauso häufig ist der Fall, wo beide nicht mehr kommunikationsbereit sind. Da ist natürlich mit Schlichtung nicht viel zu machen.
Diese Kommunikationsbereitschaft, die entsteht natürlich auch aus einem Grundwissen über Kommunikation. Insofern kann natürlich unsere Kommunikationsgesellschaft an der Stelle auch wieder aufholen.
Also das sage ich ja, das stimme ich da unangeschränkt zu. Also ich finde zum Beispiel auch an Internet-Chats oder ähnlichen, ja auch wenn ich da nicht so wahnsinnig beteiligt bin, finde ich nichts Negatives. Ich finde es im Gegenteil gut, wenn man sieht, wie kommunikationsarm unsere Welt heutzutage geworden ist. Gerade wenn man berufstätig ist, dass man zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit hat, sich am Feierabend an den Computer zu setzen und mit wildfremden Menschen zu sprechen oder in Blogs Kommentare zu schreiben oder bei Twitter mit irgendwelchen Leuten rum zu albern, möglicherweise, aber auch ernsthafte Diskussionen zu führen. Die finde ich gut und das ist natürlich immer ein Ansatz. Wenn man kommuniziert, dann ist auch immer die Möglichkeit da. Also ich will mal meine tägliche Erfahrung, die ich, ich bin ja sozusagen kein großer, aber ich bin auf jeden Fall berufsbedingter Kommunikator, weil wir immer Konflikte lösen müssen, sagen, der erste Schritt, um Konflikte zu lösen, das gilt für das Internet, wie für das reale Leben, ist nach meiner Erfahrung eigentlich immer der, dass man die Menschen irgendwo erstmal persönlich anspricht. Das kann man übers Internet, natürlich. Also ich halte es in Fällen mit verhärteten Fronten eigentlich immer so und mache damit extrem gute Erfahrungen, dass ich mir sage, ich mache mal nicht das, was der Anwalt immer typischerweise macht, irgendwelche Drohbriefe oder Fax zu schreiben, gerade in so komplizierten Fällen habe ich es mir zur Angewohnheit gemacht, auch wenn es manchmal schwerfällt, weil ich weiß, dass die andere Seite nicht zugänglich ist, einfach mal anzurufen, mit den Menschen zu sprechen. Also nicht übereinander sprechen. Du hast ja im Internet häufig die Situation, da wird jemand, wie heißt das, gedisst, der hat jemanden Mist gemacht und dann reden alle anderen nur noch über den. Das drischt sozusagen auch. Alle fallen sozusagen über den Betreffenden her. Da ist genau derselbe Ansatz richtig. Da müsste man dann vielleicht mal wieder einen finden, der dann mal zu dem dahin geht oder den mal anmeldet und sagt, sollen wir nicht mal darüber sprechen. Da finde ich schon, dass du das richtig sagst. Da gibt es immer Möglichkeiten, aber die sind im Internetbereich und im realen Leben nicht zu unterschiedlich. Ich rufe immer gerne überraschend an und sage, also hallo, hier ist ich bin das jetzt hier. Da hast du teilweise dann nach zwei, drei Minuten, wenn ich das erste Mal das höre, dass Leute dann zu mir sagen, ja das hätte ich jetzt aber nicht gedacht, dass man mit ihnen so freundlich reden kann. Ja, die sachliche Differenz.
Überraschungsmoment auf seiner Seite.
Ja natürlich, aber es ist auch häufig so, dass gerade die knorrigsten Gegner dann meistens unheimlich zugänglich werden, weil dieses Kommunikationsdefizit halt aufgehoben wird und man mit denen einfach mal spricht.
Am Ende sind es alles kleine Jungen, mit denen man Aufmerksamkeit hat.
Wir sind alles nur Menschen, ob jetzt im virtuellen oder im realen Bereich. Und diesen Ansatz müsste man weiter verfolgen, um vielleicht auch den Erfolg zu haben, die Justiz damit zu entlasten. Weil Prozesse oder Anklagen sind natürlich immer nur die letzte Möglichkeit, die man in Angriff nehmen sollte. Für viele ist es allerdings so, dass gerade auch im Internet, um wieder auf das Thema zu kommen, die juristische Keule ist heutzutage eigentlich immer die erste Wahl. Also es ist fast eine reflexartige Handlung bei beantragten Äußerungen oder Ähnliches. Da ruft man nicht mal den anderen an und sagt, hör mal, war das jetzt nötig, dass du mich als Vollidioten bezeichnest? Oder als Spacko oder irgendwie solche Sachen? Habe ich denn alles gehabt?
Ja, das gibt es.
Ich hatte nur mal ein Beispiel zu nennen. Da hat jemand, ein relativ guter Auto, in einem relativ bekannten Weblog, ein deutsches Showsternchen, als Promihure bezeichnet. Promihure. Das war also diese Zeit, als bei Thomas Gottschalk diese Nadels und so auf dem Sofa gesessen haben. Er meinte natürlich Promiluder und nicht Promihure. Die Synapsen haben nicht richtig geschaltet, was Falsches geschrieben. Das dauerte keine drei Wochen. Da war die Anwaltsabmahnung da. Wenn vielleicht der Anwalt oder die Betroffene oder ihr Manager da mal angerufen hätte und gesagt haben, was schreibst du denn da? Ich finde das nicht gut. Auch wenn das ironisch gemeint ist, dass ich als Ure hätte der sich an den Kopf gesetzt, das tut mir aber leid, das ist mir gar nicht so gemeint. So war das dann so Abmahnung. Das kam dann fast zum Prozess und man musste dann miteinander diskutieren, wie das gemeint war. Wäre alles vermeidbar, wenn man einfach mal aufeinander zugehen würde und der anderen Seite auch nicht immer das Denkbar-Böseste unterstellt. Also ist es schon möglich, da was zu machen.
Ja, so eine ähnliche Eindrückung macht auch die aktuelle politische Debatte im Bezug auf das Internet auch, so dass da zu wenig geredet und zugehört wird. Also derzeit gibt es eine massive Diskussion auf allen Fronten, was ja auch schon einige Themen hier angesprochen, rund um die Freiheit als solche. Da gibt es ja auch immer die unterschiedlichsten Vorstellungen darüber, was das jetzt beinhalten sollte. Man gewinnt teilweise allerdings auch den Eindruck in der Debatte in Deutschland, dass so an dem Wort Freiheit auch immer so ein bisschen so ein Malus dran klebt. Das ist immer dieses so, da wollen jetzt Leute wieder frei sein und da ihre Freiheit ausleben. Das ist ja irgendwie verdächtigt, so ein Unterton, der da immer wieder rauskriegt. Und man schießt sich jetzt einfach im besonderen Maße aufs Internet ein. Die Gründe haben wir ja hier schon erörtert, denke ich mal. Das hat halt auch viel mit dem Nicht-Kennen zu tun. Und jetzt sind auch die Fronten da enorm verhärtet. Auf der einen Seite gibt es so die Szene, die schreit Internet-Ausdrucker und überhaupt schaltet doch mal den Rechner ein und ihr seid ja noch nicht mal auf Facebook. Und die andere Seite klappt irgendwie genauso weg und schreit halt darauf ein, ihr wollt ja alle nur Bombenbau-Anleitungen austauschen, Kinderpornografie unter das Volk bringen und euch zu terroristischen Absprachen irgendwie in eurem finsteren Chat treffen. Das geht ja nun, so geht es ja nun auch nicht. Wie kann man denn da eine Brücke bauen? Also das ist, sind die Fronten so verhärtet aus deiner Wahrnehmung oder ist es sozusagen nur das letzte Aufschreien einer alten Generation, die danach in Rente geht und dann entspannt sich die Sache wieder?
Also es ist beides der Fall. Also ich bin relativ entsetzt darüber, wie in den letzten Monaten das böse Internet zum politischen Thema geworden ist, nämlich einfach mit der klaren Prämisse, das ist eine Bedrohung für die Gesellschaft. Also das Internet wird ausgemacht als etwas, was schädlich ist und was zu bekämpfen ist eigentlich. Also das Internet in eine negative Konnotation. Das wäre ungefähr genauso vermessen zu sagen, wie damals, aber dass es solche Stimmen gab, ist ja wohl auch. Telefon ist Teufelszeug, da können ja Bankraub und Erpressung und Menschenraub darüber verabredet werden. Da kommt ein ganz böser Zungenschlag gegenüber der Online-Welt rein. Nicht nur aus Unverständnis, sondern ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass man eben krampfhaft danach sucht, mal wieder ein geeignetes Feindbild zu finden, dass eine gewisse Werteordnung legitimieren kann. Und diese Vorbehalte gegen die Online-Welt, die kommen ja aus allen Parteien. Da ist ja keine Partei davor gefeiert. Es gibt ja auch durchaus zum Beispiel, wo man es jetzt nicht vermuten würde, bei den Grünen, die durch ihr Abstimmungsverhalten im Bundestag, was die Zensurgesetze, das Zugangserschwörungsgesetz angeht, doch gezeigt haben, dass sie da selbst schon auf der skeptischen Seite sind, weil sie eben denken, das Internet ist etwas Böses. Also da gibt es Vorbehalte überall. Und ich glaube, diese Vorbehalte sind auf der einen Seite einfach, um das Feindbild wiederzuhaben, nach dem Motto, wo grenzen wir uns ab? Wo kommt die Bedrohung her? Und auf der anderen Seite ist es denke ich auch eine doch in den letzten Monaten insbesondere deutlich gewordene Verunsicherung auf Seiten der Politiker, die ja selber häufig mit dem Internet nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu tun zu haben. Also ich rede jetzt von der Generation Müntefering, vielleicht auch von der Generation Merkel noch. Die sind verunsichert, weil sie eben merken, sie können das nicht mehr händeln. Sie haben das nicht mehr unmittelbar im Griff, was da stattfindet. Und was mich besonders erschüttert ist eigentlich, ich habe das Gefühl, dass das, was diese politische Generation am meisten stört, ist, dass ihnen da eine sachliche, argumentative Stimme entgegenschlägt. Also genau das, was eigentlich neu ist auch am Internet, was den Meinungsbildungsprozess angeht, nämlich, dass die Menschen, jeder Einzelne sozusagen, plötzlich eine Stimme hat. Und dass diese Stimmen nicht nur einzeln ankommen, sondern sozusagen auch als Chor ankommen. Ich will jetzt nicht mein bestes Beispiel, was sicherlich in Berlin am meisten Aufsehen erregt hat, ist die Online-Petition gegen Internetsperren. Da zeigte sich, dass da Zahlen zusammenkommen, die ja irgendwo auch mobilisiert werden mussten. Also es tröpfelte am Anfang vor sich hin und am Ende waren es beeindruckende 130.000 Unterzeichner. Das ist natürlich angekommen, wo das herkommt. Und das ist eine tiefe Verunsicherung, dass man eben sozusagen nicht mehr über die Heute-Nachrichten oder über das Rundfunk-Interview im Morgenmagazin zur Bevölkerung spricht, die Bevölkerung aufklärt, der Bevölkerung erklärt und sagt, warum ich als Politiker die bessere Wahl bin, sondern dass, sobald man erklärt und aufklärt, die Antwort kommt, was erzählt ihr denn für einen Blödsinn? Das stimmt doch alles gar nicht. Oder es stimmt doch vieles nicht. Oder erzählt ihr mal lange, wir wissen doch, es ist anders. In jedweder Richtung. Also gar nicht auf politische Richtungen bezogen, sondern es kommt ein sachliches Feedback, dass die Leute sagen, wollt ihr uns für dumm verkaufen? Was erzählst du da? Mein Erleben ist ein anderes. Und dass Politiker dann auch plötzlich merken, da schlägt mir eine Stimme entgegen. Und das ist diese Skepsis, die dann ja auch in den Eigenreihen, zum Beispiel, wenn dann irgendeine Politikerin, die die Stimmen bei der Bundespräsidentenwahl auszählt, die Frechheit hat, das Ergebnis über Twitter vorher schon, wenn auch verklausuliert, zu verkündigen. Da geht die Welt unter. Aber nur die politische Welt. Der normale Bürger oder der Internetnutzer fragt sich ja, das ist doch super. Da wird der Prozess doch mal transparent. Wer leidet jetzt darunter, dass ich das 25 Minuten vorher weiß, als es vielleicht die ARD weiß? Das ist doch gut. Und da kommt eine tiefe Verunsicherung zum Ausdruck, die für mich ein klares Signal ist, da ist auch Angst inzwischen, dass man das nicht mehr greifen kann.
Gerade bei diesem Fall fand ich es so unglaublich, dass dann gleich diese Diskussion über Twitter-Störsender... Ja, ich weiß, dass das so lustig ist.
Also, da muss man ja sagen, wenn Bundestagsabgeordnete sich selber Störsender in den Bundestag bauen, dann muss man sagen, dann ist es natürlich in die demokratische Institution schlechthin. Da würde etwas mit dem Selbstverständnis des Abgeordneten nicht stimmen, der dem deutschen Volke unterworfen ist. Und mein Gott, warum soll der Abgeordnete nicht über Twitter schreiben? Warum soll er das nicht tun? Aber wir kommen dann direkt zu dem zweiten Punkt. Das ist das, was mich jetzt wirklich bedrückt oder auch wirklich skeptisch stimmt. In diesem Chor stimmen ja inzwischen auch die jetzt aus ihrer eigenen Sicht ja plötzlich unglaublich benachteiligt in normalen Medien ein. Also Fernsehen, Rundfunk und Presse. Gerade diese Twitter-Geschichte hat ihnen ja ihre eigenen Grenzen aufgezeigt. Nämlich, dass plötzlich möglicherweise auf Twitter oder in einem Web-Blog eher was drin steht, als sie es sozusagen als Sprachrohr der Politik verkünden können. Und das macht mich jetzt wirklich ein bisschen besorgt, dass sozusagen nicht nur eine Stimme in diesem Chor singt, nämlich die Politik, die das Internet nicht versteht oder das Internet als Feindbild braucht. Und dass jetzt auch die in Anführungsstrichen etablierten Medien in diesem Chor einstimmen und sagen, das geht aber nicht. Denn das ist ja nicht durch seriöse, ausgebildete Journalisten gefiltert und vorher geprüft. Da kommt eine gewisse Front auf die Online-Community zu, die sicherlich noch Probleme verursachen wird. Aber, und jetzt die Conclusio, also die Schlussfolgerung, sozusagen, ich glaube, es kann letztendlich nur ein Aufbäumen sein. Das wird keinen Erfolg mehr haben, denn das Internet und die Online-Community sind eigentlich nicht in den Griff zu bekommen. Sie können nicht in den Griff zu bekommen sein. Und die Erklärung mag jetzt ein bisschen banal klingen, aber es ist so, dass die Online-Community schon deshalb sich letztendlich durchsetzen wird und ihre Existenzberechtigung nachweisen wird, wenn man das Internet halt einfach nicht abschalten und auch nicht mehr so regulieren kann. Nicht, dass man es nicht könnte und vielleicht auch wollte, aber das Problem ist, es geht aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen nicht. Wenn du heute anfängst, das Internet zu regulieren, dann werden die wirtschaftlichen Folgen so gravierend sein, dass man früher oder später davon wieder Abstand nehmen muss. Ich will jetzt nicht das Beispiel Nordkorea bringen, aber Nordkorea ist auch deswegen ein Land, das praktisch noch in der Steinzeit lebt, weil es sich eben der Online-Entwicklung komplett verschlossen hat. Und der Versuch, so etwas bei uns zurückzudrehen, in ganz anderen Nuancen natürlich, unterstelle keinem, dass er nordkoreanisch oder chinesisch oder iranische Verhältnisse will, dieser Versuch wird zum Scheitern verurteilt sein, weil natürlich dann auch die Wirtschaft nicht mehr kommunizieren kann, oder eingeschränkt werden wird.
Ich meine, das liegt natürlich jetzt auch gerade auf dem Tementisch von der Bundestagswahl, Stichwort Killerspiele, da wird halt ein Wirtschaftszweig, also die Forderung liegt auf dem Tisch. Ich meine, wer das jetzt im Einzelnen vertritt oder nicht, das ändert sich sowieso gerade jede Woche, aber immer wieder flammt halt auf so dieses Memen, ja, ich war, wenn die Kinder Krieg spielen im Internet, dann ist das irgendwie böse, ja, man darf nach wie vor im Spielwarenladen seine Panzer und seine kleinen Soldaten kaufen, das ist irgendwie alles in Ordnung, aber im Internet ist das auf einmal ganz böse, weil da wird das ja, dann ist das ja 3D irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wie die das irgendwie immer zusammen kriegen, aber findet ja statt. Auf der anderen Seite ist ja gerade die Computerspieleindustrie eine der wenigen Computerindustrie überhaupt, die in Deutschland überhaupt eine Signifikanz weltweit erreicht haben.
Und die Geld verdienen, ja.
Die Geld verdienen und die auch Arbeitsplätze schaffen und die auch junge Leute heranbilden.
Ich kann da nur eine gefühlsmäßige Äußerung machen. Ich denke, dass die Abschaffung von Videospielen bzw. die Einschränkung dieses Marktes für die Leute, die das letztendlich durchsetzen wollen, weit gefährlicher wäre, als wenn sie zum Beispiel anfangen würden, wirklich effektiv die Meinungsfreiheit im Internet zu beschränken. Also durch zum Beispiel durch die Internetüberwachungsagentur, die erstmal Webblogs lizenzieren muss. Nach dem Motto, das kann ja nicht jeder ins Internet schreiben, sondern muss erstmal eine Lizenz dafür bekommen.
Wie das jetzt im Rahmen der Medien-Dietze, Grundfunk, Staatsvertrag, ja auch schon diskutiert wird.
Es wird ja diskutiert, dass jeder, der Radio im Internet machen will oder Fernsehen machen will, eine Lizenz braucht. Das würde eher noch durchgehen, weil man das einfach ahnungslos gut verkaufen kann, dass es ja auch für den Jugendschutz und was auch immer nötig ist, dass da keine falschen Inhalte verbreitet werden. Bei den Videospielen, die ja zur Generation Freizeit gehören, da denke ich, ist das Potenzial des Protests fast noch größer, weil da kann ich mir ehrlich nicht vorstellen, dass die jungen Leute, die ich zum Beispiel kenne, das kampflos hinnehmen werden. Die werden sagen, das ist so der nackte Wahnsinn. Was wollte denn von uns? Wir sind doch nicht alles Amokläufer und ähnliches. Wir lassen uns doch hier nicht unsere mitunter vielleicht auch bevorzugte Freizeitbeschäftigung wegnehmen. Also das Risiko, dass es hier knallt, vorsichtig formuliert, halte ich für größer, als wenn zum Beispiel die Meinungsfreiheit teilweise eingeschränkt werden sollte oder solche Lizenzmodelle kommen, weil das wirklich ans Eingemachte geht, dieser Generation, die sowieso schon nicht mehr sehr politikaffin ist. Also das sind ja dann die Menschen, die dann sagen, dieser Herr Müntefering in Berlin oder der Herr Kauder von der CDU oder so, wenn die da im Fernsehen sind, das sagt mir nichts. Dass die dann sagen, das können nicht die Leute sein, die uns unsere Freizeitmöglichkeiten wegnehmen.
Die Herren, die dann sich auf ihren Parteien mit Reiseschreibmaschinen ablichten.
Ja, natürlich. Da sehe ich, das glaube ich nicht, dass das kommt. Das kommt vielleicht noch dazu zu der Diskussion.
Das macht ja schon den Eindruck, das zeigt ja auch die ganze Diskussion um die Piratenpartei, ohne auf die jetzt sonderlich eingehen zu wollen, dass sich jetzt auf jeden Fall was bewegt hat. Die Diskussion gibt es ja schon seit langem und da ist jetzt schon so viel angesprochen, wo ich noch mal drauf eingehen wollte. Also einerseits, ich stimme dir total zu, irgendwie formiert sich da eine Bewegung. Also die Diskussion, Politik, Internet gibt es schon lange, der Chaos Computer Club, der Füllboot, viele andere Organisationen, die ganzen Arbeitskreise, die sie gebildet haben, alle haben irgendwie einzelne Themen thematisiert, aber irgendwie hat es keinen interessiert. Insbesondere diese Meinungsgeschichte greift irgendwie nicht. Interessanterweise ist es aber jetzt ausgerechnet wirklich eine Zensurdebatte, also das, wo du ja auch selber sagst, das ist ja dann noch, was weiß ich, so ein unsexy Thema, die hat es jetzt irgendwie geschafft, das Fass zum Überlaufen zu bringen, also zumindest fängt es an zu quälen über die Dimension der Auswirkungen, denke ich, wird man sich ein paar Monate dann noch unterhalten müssen. Siehst du denn da auch, dass da jetzt sozusagen schon so ein neues Selbstverständnis sich entwickelt hat? Also ist das jetzt erstmal nur so ein reines Medienphänomen oder nimmst du da auch schon eine Bewegung wahr, die jetzt eine andere Qualität mit sich bringt?
Es ist eine Bewegung, die, ich will es mal so formulieren, es hätte vielleicht vor 80 Jahren oder so was, wenn man angefangen hätte zu versuchen, das Telefon zu verbieten oder vor 100 Jahren, hätte es vielleicht eine Bewegung gegeben für ein freies Telefon. Wenn das damals sich so schnell verbreitet hätte wie das Internet, hätten die Leute gesagt, nehmt uns diese Möglichkeit nicht weg. Wir finden es total super, dass wir mit unseren Verwandten, dass wir nicht drei Tage reisen müssen, um die zu besuchen, dass wir mit denen sprechen können. Nehmt uns das doch nicht weg, bloß weil man übers Telefon auch Leute belästigen kann oder sogar Verbrechen verabreden kann. Und so sehe ich diese Bewegung auch heute, denn es vereinen sich darin die unterschiedlichsten Ansichten und auch die unterschiedlichsten Lebensweisen. Einfach weil die sagen, wir nutzen das Internet als Kommunikationsmedium und als Teil unseres Lebens auf sicherlich unterschiedlichste Art und Weise. Aber wir wollen uns nicht vorschreiben lassen, solange es im legalen Bereich ist, wie wir es zu nutzen haben. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch diese, was du ja andeutest, dieser große Konsens, wo auch Leute dann plötzlich miteinander am Tisch sitzen, deren Lebensweise eigentlich oder Lebenskultur wenig damit zu tun hat. Ich führe ja viele solche Gespräche. Da sind Leute, die sitzen in Konzernen, die sind im Daily-Business eingespannt. Also der typische Manager-Typ, der sagt, warum soll ich mich zensieren lassen. Ja, es kann doch nicht sein, dass ich mich nicht mehr frei bewegen darf. Und bis zu völlig anderen Lebensentwürfen, die vereint plötzlich die Meinung, jetzt ist ein Punkt erreicht, wo wir nicht mehr Ja sagen können oder das nicht mehr akzeptieren können, dass hier Vorschriften gemacht werden, die unsere Freiheit beschränken. Also Freiheitsbeschränkung kann ja möglicherweise erforderlich sein. Das Problem ist nur, alle diese Leute mit ihren unterschiedlichen Entwürfen sehen nicht, wieso muss die Freiheit des Internets leiden. Es gibt dafür keine sachlichen Gründe. Und deswegen gibt es das schon eine Bewegung. Das Interessante ist eben daran, dass sie so ein breites Spektrum erfasst. Also vom Wissenschaftler bis zum grünen alternativen Aussteiger. Der eine sitzt in seinem Büro an der Universität, der andere vor seinem Notebook im Freibad.
Und das Establishment ist ein bisschen schockiert.
Ja, ich glaube...
Ist das nicht auch ein bisschen absurd? Ich meine, da wurde jetzt jahrelang darüber diskutiert, über Politikverdrossenheit und dass man mehr Partizipation haben will.
Ich halte die Deutschen gerade bei diesem Thema für intelligenter, als die Politiker sie halten. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel jetzt in meinem Familienkreis denke, meine Mutter ist jetzt auch über 60, würde gemeinhin zur älteren Generation gerechnet werden. Aber sie hat vor zwei, drei Jahren auch gelernt, wie man E-Mails schreibt und wie man am Arbeitsplatz online Zeitungen liest. Ich hoffe, ihr Chef hört nicht zu. Und selbst die sagt, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, wieso kann ich plötzlich nicht mehr, sollen da irgendwelche Stoppschilder kommen? Und was kommt als nächstes, wenn ich heute, ist es das Killer-Thema Kinderpornografie, was ist es morgen? Kann ich dann morgen die Zeitung nicht mehr lesen, die ich will oder das Weblog nicht mehr lesen, das mich interessiert, bloß weil irgend einer sagt, nein, das ist aber nicht gut für dich. Das ist ja gerade so, dass solche Leute auch gerade völlig unverdächtigt des Interesses an solchen Dingen wie Kinderpornografie sind. Aber die begreifen alle, wenn so ein Anfang gemacht wird, dann ist der nächste Schritt nicht weit. Und die Debatte der letzten Tage zeigt uns ja, dass die nächsten Schritte längst geplant sind. Also das Totschlagsargument Kinderpornografie ist natürlich nur der Türöffner dafür, das Internet und insbesondere die Meinungsfreiheit zu regulieren. Demnächst wird also auch der sozialtherapeutische Ansatz bei politischen Meinungen gepflegt werden. Natürlich zuerst nur bei extremen Meinungen.
Das ist ja immer das beliebte Nazi-Propaganda, was ja auch sehr debil war. Hassseiten, sehr schön.
Ja gut, aber das Beispiel Nazi-Propaganda. Meinungsfreiheit umfasst natürlich auch die Freiheit, unbeliebte Dinge zu denken. Und Stoppschilder vor fremde Meinungen aufzustellen, hindert erstens nicht daran, diese Meinungen trotzdem zur Kenntnis zu nehmen. Die werden nach wie vor umgehbar sein. Und B, sie werden natürlich den gegenteiligen Effekt haben. Denn vor allem alle Dinge, vor denen ein Stoppschild steht, die bekommen natürlich dann erst mal den Hauch des Interessanten. Und die werden ja sozusagen dann staatlich geradelt. Also ich würde es nicht für ausgeschlossen halten, dass in zwei, drei Jahren nicht wenige Leute stolz darauf sein werden, dass vor ihrem Webblog oder was auch immer ein Stoppschild steht. Weil dadurch zeichnen sie sich ja als nicht konform und als nicht tolerabel aus. So und vielleicht als justiziabel sogar heraus. Also da ist viel im Schwang und das verstehen die Leute nicht. Und da muss ich auch sagen, verstehe ich die Politiker nicht, weil auch die normalen Menschen, also die nicht Internetaffin sind, aber die das Internet als schon Nutzen, die wissen nicht, was das soll.
Ich meine, gerade bei dem Fall Nazi-Propaganda wird es natürlich extrem schwierig, insbesondere weil wir ja auch in unserem Rechtssystem sind ja dann entsprechende Äußerungen, bestimmte Äußerungen, gewisse Äußerungen verboten.
Ja gut, aber dann können solche Seiten auch vom Netz genommen werden.
Ja, aber wie ist denn das so mit diesem, ich meine, da immer wieder den Fall Holocaust-Leugnung, ja, ist halt eine Tatsache und keine Meinung. Da hat sich, glaube ich, auch das Bundesverfassungsgericht mal entsprechend geäußert. Die Frage ist, wie genau lässt sich das dann sozusagen in dem Fall noch abreißen? Du hast ja eben schon gesagt, Meinung ist halt auch die Meinung, die man jetzt nicht für richtig hält. Wie genau ist denn das an der Stelle überhaupt definiert?
Also es gibt nur ein sehr geringes Spektrum von Äußerungen, die überhaupt verboten sind. Also man darf nicht der Meinung sein oder der Ansicht sein, es wäre alles verboten, was sozusagen nicht auf dem Boden des Grundgesetzes steht. Natürlich, ich darf die allermeisten Meinungen und Ansichten vertreten, auch wenn sie nicht grundgesetzkonform sind. Also es gibt kein Gesetz, das es mir verbietet, zum Beispiel den Kommunismus wieder zu predigen. Ich kann auch den Stalinismus predigen und ähnliche Dinge. Genau diese Punkte, die du angesprochen hast, sind eigentlich die einzigen, die bei uns in Deutschland als Ansichten, bzw. als Meinungen verboten sind. Das sind eben Dinge, die konnotiert sind mit dem Nationalsozialismus. Also insbesondere die Leugnung des Holocaust, die eben keine Meinung ist. Das hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht in der Tat gesagt. Wer also zum Beispiel sagt, der Holocaust hat nicht stattgefunden, oder auch sagt, ich meine, der Holocaust hat wahrscheinlich nicht stattgefunden, der macht sich strafbar. Das ist klar, aber das sind natürlich sehr wenige Dinge. Deswegen muss ich auch ehrlich sagen, ich bin da etwas besorgt darüber, dass das alles so in einen Topf geschmissen wird. Denn einfach zu sagen, alles, was sozusagen ins Extreme geht, das ist Hasspropaganda und muss deshalb vor den Augen der Menschen verborgen werden, das ist schon ein sehr weitgehender Ansatz. Denn strafrechtlich ist solchen Ansichten in der Regel nicht beizukommen. Es gibt auch zum Beispiel kein gesetzliches Verbot gegen islamistische Propaganda, solange sie sich in gewissen Grenzen hält, wenn sie zum Beispiel nicht volksverhetzend ist. Das sind natürlich immer diese Extrembeispiele, wo man sagen kann, das ist doch eigentlich nur super, wenn das aus dem Netz genommen wird. Aber mein Problem, das ich mit solchen Dingen habe, ist, dass man sehr schnell in Grauzonen hineinkommt. Der Bundesverfassungsschutz-Präsident hat jetzt vor Tagen bei dieser Konferenz selber gesagt, unser Problem ist, dass man zum Beispiel rechtsradikale Seiten, also die Hassseiten, als solche gar nicht erkennt, weil die so geschickt gemacht sind. Und damit umreißt der Präsident des Bundesverfassungsschutzes eigentlich schon das große Problem, das heutzutage damit besteht, solche Inhalte überhaupt zu identifizieren. Denn auch die Propagandisten sind natürlich längst nicht mehr so dumm, dass sie irgendwelche blöden Parolen da reinschreiben, die liest ja keiner, das interessiert sich ja keiner dafür, sondern die ideologische Bauernfängerei, die wird ja auf subtile Art und Weise gemacht. Du kennst das ja aus dem Real Life, dann mit diesen Freizeitorganisationen, da wird eben eine Ferienfreizeit gemacht, die dann in der Konnotation einfach nationalsozialistisch angehaucht ist oder so was. Und so ist es auch bei den Internetseiten. Nur ich mache mir dann Sorgen, wenn selbst der Verantwortliche dafür sagt, wir können es ja eigentlich gar nicht erkennen, wer soll denn dann entscheiden, wo die Stoppschilder da vorgestellt werden oder was zensiert werden soll. Denn wenn ich es nicht erkennen kann, dann kann ich es eigentlich auch nicht verbieten, weil dann steht da nichts drin. Das heißt also, da muss interpretiert werden, da muss dann reingelesen werden. Und da muss dann sozusagen auf der Auslegungsebene gesagt werden, ihr seid Nazis, euch nehme ich aus dem Netz, oder ihr seid noch, sag ich mal, nur rechts, ihr dürft das sagen, ja. Also das ist eben das Problem mit der, ich nehme jetzt mal den untechnischsten Begriff, mit der Zensur, die bei uns möglicherweise über die Stoppschilder wieder Einzug hält. Es geht doch nicht um die dummdreißten Propaganda-Seiten, wo in dicken Lettern in unbeholfenem Deutsch Volksverhetzung oder ähnliches betrieben wird, sondern es geht doch um die die Seiten, die sich dann selber auch in intellektuellen Ansprüchen durchgeben und alles vermeiden, um Volksverhetzung zu betreiben. Wo also sozusagen dann diejenigen, die das überprüfen müssen, erst das Ergebnis haben müssen. Ach ja, der Herr Pritlove oder der Herr Vetter, der das liest, die würden dadurch verhetzt werden. Obwohl, wenn wir es vielleicht lesen, wir sagen, was sind das denn für Dumpfbacken? Ja, ja, zwar schön geschrieben, aber ist nicht meine Meinung.
Genau, euch ignorieren wir mal.
Ja, und da ist die Gefahr darin, dass natürlich letztendlich, letztendlich diese Stereotypen mit Hassseiten und sowas auf die wirklich gefährlichen Inhalte nicht zutreffend ist. Ja, und das ist jetzt meine private Meinung, deswegen sage ich, man kann andere Ansichten, auch wenn sie extrem und wenn sie vielleicht Hass erfüllt sind und wenn sie vielleicht auch ansatzweise in die falsche Richtung gehen, nicht dadurch bekämpfen, indem man sie aus dem Netz rausnimmt, sondern man kann letztendlich nur die argumentative Auseinandersetzung suchen. Man kann zum Beispiel Jugendlichen, die als besonders gefährdet gelten, nicht damit beikommen, dass man das vor deren Blicken entzieht. Was wäre das zum Beispiel auch für ein Schulunterricht, wo man nicht über Extremismus redet und zum Beispiel auch im Schulbuch extremistische Propaganda beispielsweise bespricht, sondern wo man sagt, so was gibt es ja gar nicht. Und wenn es das gibt, ihr dürft das nicht lesen, dann muss man sich argumentativ mit auseinandersetzen. Und gerade die Stärke einer Demokratie zeichnet sich ja eigentlich dadurch aus, dass die Menschen an die Demokratie glauben. Und das, was im Moment in der Politik stattfindet, ist eigentlich ein Beweis dafür, dass man oben, im untechnischen Sinne als in der Politik, nicht mehr großes Vertrauen in das Demokratieverständnis der Bevölkerung hat. Dass man die also für anfällig hält. Und nur dieser pädagogische Ansatz nach dem Motto, wir verbieten das alles und dann ist es nicht mehr existent, der wird natürlich dann dazu führen, dass wir die Freiheit damit verteidigen, indem wir die Freiheit abschaffen.
Das ist die Gefahr.
Das ist die Gefahr, ja.
Du hast ja vorhin schon auch die Rolle der Medien in dem ganzen Spiel mit eingebracht. Ich fand das auch schon immer sehr fraglich, insbesondere im Hinblick auf die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Weil es gab ja eigentlich, also ich hatte zumindest den Eindruck, dass es in den Medien, also in den traditionellen Medien, im Netz sah das natürlich ganz anders aus, eigentlich überhaupt gar keine wirkliche inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung damit gab. Es wurde halt so in diesen üblichen Nachrichtenticker-Style so, ja, jetzt hat die Regierung da ein neues Gesetz in Planung und da geht es irgendwie um, hm hm hm und kommen wir jetzt wieder zu Michael Jackson. Und das, obwohl es sie eigentlich ja extrem betrifft. Ja, und ich habe mich immer gefragt, warum reden die da nicht drüber? Verstehen die es nicht? Ja, also ist da sozusagen auch schon so die Unkenntnis über die Auswirkungen so groß, dass das komplett an ihnen vorbeigeht oder wollen sie nicht, weil sie auch selber, wie wir vorhin schon gesagt haben, so das Internet als die Kanalisation der Gesellschaft begreifen, wo man am besten gar nicht erst den Deckel hebt, weil da kommen dann nur so komische Gestalten raus. Weil, vielleicht noch eins hinterher, gerade jetzt bei diesem Zugangs-Erschwerungsgesetz, was ja auch für dich ein furchtbarer Urformismus ist, meiner Sicht, da war es dann auch bis kurz davor, bis diese Petition losgeknallt ist, genauso. Es gab da irgendwie reine Verlautbarung, dann auf einmal drehte das Netz komplett frei, im besten Sinne des Wortes, und auf einmal wurde das reflektiert. Auf einmal sah man sich zumindest in den Online-Teilen irgendwie genötig, da doch mal Bezug zu nehmen und das Ganze auch vielleicht zu hinterfragen. Da gab es dann auch mal wieder diese komischen Brüche, wie zum Beispiel in der Zeit, ja, das ist der Untertitel bei dem Interview, dem Gespräch mit der Franziska Heine, Ursula von der Leyen. Im Internet ging es dann sozusagen um dieses Gesetz, und in der Print-Version gab es dann...
Vor dann die Freigabe von Kinderpornografie.
Genau, da wurde halt über das Verbot von Kinderpornografie geredet, worum es ja nie ging, weil das war schon vorher verboten. Also was geht dir da durch den Kopf, wenn du irgendwie die Rolle der Medien antwortest?
Also die Rolle der Medien, auf deine Seite würde ich gleich eine Ehrenrettung der Medien versuchen, aber zunächst muss ich sagen, ich habe den Verdacht, dass es den Qualitätsjournalismus, also den investigativen, verständigen, aufklärerischen, mutigen, auf der Seite der Demokratie stehenden, durchaus auch kämpferischen Journalismus so nicht mehr gibt. Und der Grund dafür ist, und das kann ich nur aus Gesprächen mit vielen Journalisten, die ich auch privat kenne, die auch teilweise meine Mandanten sind, sagen, ist die Entwicklung in der Medienwelt, die geprägt ist durch fehlende Mittel für investigativen, sorgfältigen Journalismus. Da ist einfach das Geld nicht mehr vorhanden. Die Leute, die heute auch gute Zeitungen machen sollen, sind in der Regel zwar noch ordentlich bezahlt, aber sie müssen auch sehr viel dafür arbeiten. Und es gibt nicht mehr die Möglichkeit, wie wir sie früher mal kannten, dass zum Beispiel solche Magazine wie der Stern oder so was oder Spiegel, das sind ja noch so Flaggschiffe. Aber auch selbst bei denen nimmt ja die Zahl der Entfüllungen sozusagen drastisch ab, wenn man sich überlegt, also wenn ich aus meiner Kindheit oder Jugend überlege, da ratterte der Spiegel jeden Montag, kamen die Skandale raus und alle hatten Angst vor dem Montag. Ja, diese Zeiten sind doch alle längst vorbei. Das liegt einfach daran, dass a, offensichtlich die Mittel nicht mehr vorhanden sind und b, vielleicht auch die Lust, so was zu machen, unglaublich erlamt ist. Vielleicht auch vor dem Hintergrund, und das ist dann die Kritik, die man an den Medien üben muss, dass letztendlich, habe ich das Gefühl, inzwischen auch so eine Kapitulation vor der Online-Welt stattfindet. Dass also inzwischen fast die Neigung bei dem Journalismus offensichtlich so ist, dass man sich zurücklehnt und wartet auf die Themen, die aus der Online-Welt hochgespült werden. Und da kommt man genau zu diesen beiden Punkten, Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Zugangserschwörungsgesetz. Diese beiden Dinge haben ja erstmals gezeigt, dass es erst mal einen Verlautmachungsjournalismus gibt, der also nicht kritisch hinterfragt, wo also keiner mehr auf die Idee kommt, zu überprüfen, was sind denn eigentlich die Grundlagen und welche Auswirkungen können diese Gesetze haben. Und erst dann, nachdem sozusagen die Argumente in der Online-Welt, in Webblogs und unabhängigen Magazinen, also netzpolitik.org zum Beispiel, ist ja heute in Berlin wahrscheinlich genauso häufig fast gelesen wie der Spiegel oder so, weil da kommen eben die Themen plötzlich her. Und das wurde vorgekaut, erklärt und irgendwann kam dann mal jemand auf die Idee zu sagen, boah, was die da schreiben, das ist ja richtig. Und dann wird das aufgegriffen und dann steht es vielleicht irgendwo erst mal in der Süddeutschen Zeitung oder in der Zeit oder im Spiegel. Und wenn es dann irgendwo dasteht, dann greifen die anderen es auch wieder auf, bis runter sozusagen zur Provinzzeitung. Wenn es also dann in den drei, vier großen Leitmedien aus Hamburg und Berlin gestanden hat, dann schreibt auch, ich will jetzt keiner Provinzzeitung zu nahe treten, aber das blatt in Osnabrück oder in Hannover einen klugen Leitartikel dazu und sagt, ja so geht es eigentlich nicht. Aber nehmen wir das noch mal positiv, das zeigt doch, diese beiden Beispiele zeigen doch, dass gerade die online Veröffentlichungen, also die freien, die nicht zu den etablierten Medien gehören, die Webblogs und die Leute, die sich um Argumente bemühen und auch um die Aufarbeitung, inzwischen fast so eine Meinungsführerschaft in diesen Punkten übernommen haben. Gerade das Zugangserschwärungsgesetz, das ist ja angesprochen, da kam in den letzten Wochen vor dieser Abstimmung eine unglaubliche Dynamik rein. Plötzlich war ein riesiges Rauschen im Blätterwald. Es müsste sich mal einer die Mühe machen, bis dieses Rauschen begonnen hat, die früheren Artikel und die späteren Artikel miteinander zu vergleichen. Da müssten dann wahrscheinlich einige etablierte und vermeintlich engagierte Journalisten vor Scham in den Boden versinken, weil sie selber nicht auf die Idee gekommen sind, dass es so ist. Also da ist, denke ich, der Zug abgefahren. Diese kritische und kämpferische Presse, die hat sich doch totgelaufen. Die sehe ich nicht mehr. Also nicht mehr, was ihre geballte Macht angeht, wie ich sie gerade dargestellt habe. Aber das ist auch nicht so schlimm, weil, wie sich zum Beispiel an diesen Themen zeigt, durchaus auch ein Korrektiv gewachsen ist, das auch Meinungen bilden und auch Tatsachen liefern kann. Es ist ja nicht nur so, dass die gesagt haben, die haben ja mit ihrer Meinung recht, sondern sind ja die Fakten für die etablierten Medien aufgearbeitet worden. Und das ist ja eigentlich eine positive Entwicklung. Also ich persönlich lese keine Printzeitungen mehr, höchstens wenn es sich nicht vermeiden lässt. Also mit anderen Worten, wenn keine UMTS-Verbindung besteht. Und deswegen muss ich sagen, ich fühle mich eigentlich zum Beispiel, wenn ich mich nur online informiere, nicht schlechter informiert, als wenn ich früher Printzeitungen gelesen habe. Und deswegen muss ich auch sagen, ich kann nicht ganz nachvollziehen, dass die Welt jetzt untergehen soll, weil die Zeitungen aus gedrucktem Papier vielleicht früher oder später voll im Ende stehen. Die Welt ist auch nicht untergegangen, als die Kühlschränke die Eislieferanten abgeliefert haben. Und gerade hier kann man optimistisch sein, weil Information nicht an das Medium gebunden ist. Also da die Tatsache, dass ein Artikel auf Papier gedruckt ist, macht ihn noch nicht besser. Es macht ihn vielleicht sogar noch besser, wenn er an Stellen und Orten abgerufen werden kann, die nicht öffentlicher Kontrolle unterliegen.
Das ist aber jetzt immer noch ein Wertewandel, der unterwegs ist. Das gedruckte Buch hat eine ganz andere Autorität gegenüber einem E-Book oder einem Geschreibsel im Internet. Ein gedruckter Artikel hat immer noch ein Aufmerksamkeitsgewicht. Du meinst, das ist bald vorbei?
Also für die gedruckten Artikel würde ich sagen, da ist es schon so. Ich denke, das macht heute keinen großen Unterschied mehr, ob ein Artikel online publiziert wird oder ob er im Print publiziert wird. Ich denke, die Wirkung des Artikels wird sich danach bemessen, wie sein Inhalt ist. Ich sehe das nicht so, dass bloß weil der Artikel im Föhtung der FAZ steht, er langfristig größere Wirkung haben wird, als einer, der online publiziert worden ist. Ich glaube, dieser Zug ist abgefahren. Was die Bücher angeht, ist es sicherlich noch etwas anders. Da stehen wir jetzt ja erst bei der Einführung der E-Books und der E-Reader. Ich habe selber noch nicht so ein Ding in der Hand gehalten. Ich bin auch ein großer Anhänger des Buches. Ich lese auch gerne und viele Bücher. Da ist es sicherlich was anderes. Aber die Zeiten, in denen Bücher in der, sozusagen gesellschaftlichen Debatte oder politischen Debatte, noch zum Zuge gekommen sind, die haben sich ja auch durch die Geschwindigkeit, mit der heute im Internet kommuniziert wird, doch weitgehend überholt. Ich will dir mal ein Beispiel nennen, das kennst du sicherlich auch noch. Als ich ins Gymnasium gegangen bin und mich politisch interessiert habe, so ab der neunten, zehnten Klasse, damals war unsere wichtigste Informationsquelle neben den Tageszeitungen eine Taschenbuchreihe, die hieß Rororor Aktuell. Da wurde Friedensbewegung, sage ich jetzt mal als Stichwort. Diese Bücher kamen so im Zweimonatstakt raus. Friedensbewegung, Atomkraft, die Themen, die uns damals interessierte haben, die wurden in Taschenbücher gepackt.
Also billig zu produzieren.
Das war sozusagen Netzpolitik-Org auf Papier.
Alle zwei Wochen ein neuer Blog eigentlich.
Ja, 120 Seiten, 150 Seiten mit Materialien im Anhang immer drin. Also versucht zu dokumentieren, was sind die Sachen. Das ist heute natürlich nicht mehr so. Heute findet man die Informationen dann eben auf diesen Seiten. Oder man findet PDFs, wo die Originaldokumente drin sind. Das Buch hat da für die aktuelle politische Debatte auch keinen großen Einfluss mehr. Eher für die grundlegenden Debatten bzw. für Grundtendenzen oder gesellschaftliche Fragen ist das natürlich immer wichtig, Bücher zu lesen. Wenn ich Kinder hätte, würde ich immer sagen, ihr müsst Bücher lesen, weil das einfach einen anderen Zugang zum Wissen auch ermöglicht. Aber dass sie jetzt großen Einfluss darauf haben, ich glaube, das ist nicht mehr so. Also aus nostalgischen Gründen finde ich zum Beispiel Bücher gut. Den Zeitungen würde ich keine großen Tränen nachweihen. Aber das sage ich ganz ehrlich. Aber dass man ohne sie nicht auskommen könnte, das sehe ich nicht. Und dass sie jetzt Kulturgut, dass der Umstand, dass etwas auf Papier steht und nicht im Bildschirm steht, dass das ein Kulturgut sein soll, da werden wir in 40, 50 Jahren sehr herzlich darüber lachen.
Vielleicht noch mal wieder zurück zu unserem eingänglichen, eingangs formulierten Thema des rechtsfreien Raums. Eine der schöneren Wendungen dazu ist das Umdrehen dieses Begriffs in das Internet darf kein bürgerrechtsfreier Raum sein. Nachdem wir jetzt schon festgestellt haben, dass Strafrecht und eigentlich auch alle anderen Paragrafen mehr als genug gelten und dazu auch noch sonstige Gesetze gibt und dass es auch teilweise im Internet durch die ganze Verdichtung auch nochmal ein extra Problem ist. Wie sieht es denn jetzt in der Hinsicht aus, dass die neuen Gesetzesbestrebungen oder auch schon ältere Gesetzesbestrebungen Bürgerrechte entfernen, generell aus der Gesellschaft mit dem Internet als Besondere?
Na gut, es hängt ja nicht alles mit Artikel 5 und der Meinungsfreiheit zusammen. Wir sehen ja einen weit umfassenderen Grundrechteabbau seit spätestens September 2001. Der Otto-Katalog 1, Otto-Katalog 2, also Otto-Schili-Kataloge für die Jüngeren, die es nicht mehr miterlebt haben. Das waren ja ganz wesentliche Einschnitte, die unser aller Leben letztendlich verändert haben, sofern wir mal in Krisensituationen kommen. Also was zum Beispiel deine Rechte in Ermittlungsverfahren angeht, was Personenkontrollen angeht, was die Möglichkeit von Hausdurchsuchungen angeht, was gerade häufig nicht gesehen wird, zum Beispiel die Kompetenzen vom Zoll und Ähnlichem, die gehen ja teilweise schon fast so weit, dass man absolut sich nackt ausziehen muss, ohne dass man es merkt. Also ich spreche jetzt hier zum Beispiel mal von Datenübermittlung zur Aufklärung von möglichen Steuerstraftaten. Also heute hat jeder Beamte, um Beispiel zu nennen, in dem Einwohner-Meldeamt, obwohl er mit deiner Thematik Steuer und nichts zu tun hat, theoretisch und auch praktisch die Möglichkeit, mal zu gucken, was hast du denn für Konten? Warum kann der das? Weil das einfach eingeführt worden ist, weil man gedacht hat, möglichst jeder, der irgendwie in der Exekutive arbeitet, sollte sich über den Status des Bürgers informieren müssen. Vielleicht findet er ja auch was Verdächtiges. Ja, also das sind ein Datenskriptis und auch ein Persönlichkeitskriptis, der einem da abverlangt wird. Der ist ganz enorm, wenn man mal in die Details geht und den merkt man selber im Alltag gar nicht. Und das ist natürlich ein ganz viel gravierenderer Abbau, als zum Beispiel die Sachen, die man vielleicht nur in Krisensituationen, wenn man mal verhaftet wird, bemerkt. Nur das macht das Ganze ja nicht besser, denn wenn ich dann Haut und Haaren selber konkret in der Situation spüre, dann kann ich mich vielleicht noch eher wehren, als wenn über mich zum Beispiel, was ja heutzutage problemlos der Fall ist, größere Datensammlungen angeräuft werden und Daten kontrolliert werden, wo ich überhaupt nicht weiß, dass das stattfindet, und welche Daten da überhaupt übermittelt werden. Also ich habe ja naturgemäß häufiger Einblick in solche Akten. Man ist dann doch teilweise erstaunlich, was auf ein paar Knopfdrucke über Personen, ihre finanziellen Verhältnisse, ihre Lebensverhältnisse usw. heute aus Datenpools gezogen werden kann. Und das ist so der schleichende Grundrechtsabbau, den man schleichend deswegen, weil man ihn nicht bemerkt. Und der hat sich bei uns schon unglaublich vollzogen. Ich warte jetzt zum Beispiel darauf. Es ist ja immer so, wenn du das zum Beispiel mal siehst, die Kontenabfrage, die ich vorhin erwähnt habe, die heute praktisch von jedem Behördenterminal ausgemacht werden kann, die wurde seinerzeit eingeführt mit dem Argument, wir müssen den Terrorismus bekämpfen. Das war also, die Einführung war, Anlass war, Terrorismusbekämpfung. Dann wurde das über mehrere Gesetzesschritte immer weiter aufgeweicht, dass es heute praktisch zum Standardinstrument geworden ist. Und da muss man einfach auch daraus lernen.
Standardinstrument, wofür?
Standardinstrument steht überall zur Verfügung. Also die Kontenabfrage wird heute auch bei Bagatellkriminalität gemacht, also Scheckbetrug.
Also es wird einfach getan oder das Recht ist weiterentwickelt?
Nein, das Recht ist aufgeweicht worden. Also die Gesetzesschritte sind immer so, da können wir vielleicht in anderen Punkten daraus lernen, dass immer so gesagt wird, wir brauchen dieses Instrument zum Kampf gegen den Terrorismus. In der ersten Fassung des Gesetzes steht dann, darf zur Aufklärung von Straftaten mit terroristischem Hintergrund 129, 129 ASTGB eingesetzt werden. Und dann kommt immer weiter die Aufweichung. Und heute sind wir also im Zeitraum vom acht Jahren so weit, dass praktisch wegen jedes Vorwurfs derartige Kontenabfragen gemacht werden können. Es ist ja heutzutage gang und gäbe, dass zum Beispiel Ermittlungsbehörden routinemäßig bei deiner Bank anfragen und sich erstmal alle Konten ausziehen lassen. Dazu brauchst du aber nicht mehr im Verdacht zu stehen, eine schwere Straftat begangen zu haben, sondern es reicht schon theoretisch, wenn man dich bei einem Ladendiebstahl erwischt hat. Ich habe das schon erlebt, dass Richter so etwas gemacht haben, angefordert haben, weil sie nicht geglaubt haben, dass der Betroffene gesagt hat, ich verdiene halt nur 1200 Euro netto im Monat, weil sich danach die Höhe der Geldstrafe bemisst. Da wird also der Kontostriptease gemacht, um festzustellen, kann ich dem vielleicht noch beim Tagessatz 5 Euro draufpacken oder so. Das fing an als Mittel gegen den Terrorismus. Heute ist das Gang und Gebe. Mach dir das mal klar, das sind deine finanziellen Verhältnisse. Das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie, warst du letzte Woche auf einem Ärztekonzert oder hast du dich da und da sehen lassen. Das sind deine finanziellen Verhältnisse von A bis Z. Die können durchleuchtet werden. Und in anderen Bereichen haben wir das genauso. Wir werden in ein, zwei Jahren die Debatte wieder haben mit den Mautgebühren. Die Mautdrücken stehen an den Autobahnen und irgendein Politiker hat damals in weiser Voraussicht reinschreiben lassen, die dürfen nur für die Zwecke der Maut verwendet werden. Also nicht für die strafrechtliche Aufklärung. Es wird kommen, wie das Abend in der Kirche, es werden Widerfälle kommen, wo man sagt, vielleicht könnten wir den Täter ja überführen, wenn wir wissen, wer ist denn dann und dann da langgefahren. Und dann wird es am Anfang aus schweren Straftaten beschränkt sein und irgendwann werden die Mautdaten ähnlich wie die Kontenabfragen genauso verwendet werden können für jeden Pups, wie heute die Kontenabfrage verwendet wird. Und das hat man in unglaublich vielen weiteren Bereichen. Es ist ja letztendlich immer nur das Bundesverfassungsgericht, das dann dem noch einen letzten Riegel vorschiebt. Ich nenne mal großer Lauschangriff. Der wurde ja auch so gestaltet, dass man praktisch nichts wahnsinnig Schlimmes gemacht haben musste, um Kameras überall in der Wohnung zu haben und Mikrofone unter dem Bett. Da hat dann letztendlich immer nur das Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt, soweit können wir nicht gehen. Aber das Bundesverfassungsgericht stellt natürlich auch immer nur die letzte Schranke auf. Man hat manchmal das Gefühl, das ist mein Gefühl, dass auch solche Gesetze wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder so, die werden bewusst verfassungswidrig gemacht in dem Wissen, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht dann sozusagen wenigstens noch das Maximale erlauben wird. Dann besteht wenigstens keine Gefahr, dass man zu wenig geregelt hat. Also die Politiker kriegen dann letztendlich immer noch das Maximum dessen, was überhaupt noch rechtsstaatlich einigermaßen vertretbar ist. Ich könnte jetzt diese Aufzählung in vielen Beispielen fortsetzen. Es ist eben dummerweise so, dass die Grundrechte, also Meinungsfreiheit, Berufsausübung, insbesondere auch Unverletzlichkeit der Wohnung, das vielleicht noch als anzusprechen. Hausdurchsuchungen sind heutzutage Standard. Wer ist das für eine Standardsituation? Da brauchst du nicht viel, damit jemand bei dir kommt. Die schlimmsten Fälle, die ich habe, Teilnahme an einer Tauschbörse. Jemand soll 5 MP3s irgendwo zum Download oder Upload zur Verfügung gestellt haben. Hausdurchsuchungen sind Standardmaßnahmen. Was inzwischen fast schon so ist, und das empfinde ich als wirklich bedrückend, ist, dass man heutzutage ja schon fast als politisch zweifelhaft gilt, wenn man sich erdreistet, darauf hinzuweisen, dass es diese Grundrechte ja gibt. Also die Tendenz ist ja inzwischen schon so, dass man sich fast argumentativ in der Defensive befindet, wenn man sagt, Moment mal, habt ihr das Grundgesetz nicht gelesen? Da sind doch diese Schranken drin. Ihr dürft das doch gar nicht. Man wird dann argumentativ in die Ecke gestellt nach dem Motto, wir wissen doch alle stillschweigend, das Grundgesetz ist doch überholt. Wir müssen doch in die Präventivgesellschaft, in den fürsorgenden Staat. Und da ist ja das Argument relativ simpel, wir wollen ja nur euer Bestes. Ich verstehe das als Politiker, ich liebe euch doch alle. Das ist das Argument. Warum habt ihr Probleme damit, eure DNA freiwillig abzugeben? Ihr müsst natürlich nicht, alle anderen machen es, aber wenn du es nicht machst, dann kommt der Richter und erzwingt es natürlich von dir. Warum gebt ihr uns die DNA nicht? Wir wollen doch nur euer Bestes. Wir wollen doch nur das Verbrechen aufklären, das Böse. Aber da kommt man in die Defensive. Und ich glaube, das ist heutzutage auch in Berlin, habe ich das Gefühl, schon fast so ein stillschweigender Konsens, dass das Grundgesetz nur noch Makulatur ist und dass man da irgendwie gucken muss, wie man da sozusagen die Haken und Ösen findet. Anders kann ich mir zum Beispiel auch solche Gesetze wie das Zugangserschwörungsgesetz nicht erklären oder die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Da wird unisono von Juristen nicht nur gesagt, das ist verfassungswidrig, das geht zu weit. Also Juristen sagen auch, ihr seid dafür gar nicht zuständig. Also wer das Grundgesetz zum Beispiel mal gelesen hat beim Zugangserschwörungsgesetz, der wird feststellen, der Bund ist gar nicht zuständig für diese Dinge. Das hat ja nichts mit Wirtschaft zu tun, das ist ja Kriminalprävention, Verhinderung. Dafür ist nicht der Bund, sondern die Länder zuständig. Aber nein, die Politiker sagen dann, wir machen das trotzdem. Und warum machen sie es? Weil sie einfach denken, sie scheinen da in so einer Verantwortung drin zu sein, uns diesen Präventionsstaat aufzudrängen. Ich glaube, diese Leute denken wirklich, sie tun uns was Gutes. Nur kann sein, dass sie sich damit etwas verschätzen, dass die meisten Leute dann doch früher oder später sagen werden, so gut finden wir das aber gar nicht. Und so viel Spaß macht es nicht, in so einer Gesellschaft zu leben, wo der Staat mir vorschreibt, was gut und was böse ist und was ich zur Kenntnis nehmen darf und was ich nicht zur Kenntnis nehmen darf.
Die politische Klasse hat mal so den Eindruck entfernt, sich eigentlich von ihrer eigenen Grundlage. Ich meine, wenn man sozusagen das Grundgesetz immer nur in seinen Randbereichen auslegt und dann so, ja, das sind ja einfach so permanente Grenzgänger. Man könnte schon sarkastisch sagen, das sind alles Republikflüchtlinge, die sich sozusagen nur im Grenzstreifen bewegen und wenn man nicht aufpasst, sozusagen die Republik verlassen.
Ja, das ist so, das ist die Verfassungstreue erodiert unglaublich. Und zwar komischerweise bei den Leuten, die die Verfassung eigentlich bewahren sollen. Man sieht eben daran, dass so eine Verfassung wie ein Grundgesetz letztendlich auch nur bedrucktes Papier ist. Und wenn es nicht ins Konzept passt, dann kann daran eben geschraubt werden. Und dann wird auch dran geschraubt. Und da muss man dann eben auch so sagen, das muss man eben auch aufstehen und sagen, das geht so nicht, ihr könnt das nicht machen. Unabhängig von den Buchstaben des Grundgesetzes gibt es eben elementare Werte, die sakrosankt sind. Und wir kommen halt in vielen Teilbereichen mittlerweile dazu, dass man als Bürger sagen muss, und auch gerade so Zugangserschwärungsgesetz oder Vorratsdatenspeicherung, das sind ja Dinge, die jeden unmittelbar betreffen. Das ist ja nicht so, dass ich sagen kann, es trifft ja nur den islamistischen Hassprediger. Auch deine und meine Daten werden für sechs Monate auf Halde gespeichert, ohne dass ein Grund ersichtlich ist, warum, weil ich mich als gesetzestreuer Bürger fühle. Aber sie werden halt erst mal gespeichert. Also schon dieses potenzielle Misstrauen, das einem der Staaten entgegenbringt. So hat der Motto, gib mir erst mal alle deine Daten. Und nach sechs Monaten lasse ich dich dann sozusagen raus aus diesem Generalverdacht. Das muss man sich einfach mal klar machen, welches Misstrauen auch da dem einzelnen unbescholtenen Bürger gegenübergebracht wird. Und das ist einfach Ausdruck, Ausfluss einer offensichtlichen, wie soll ich das sagen, das ist fast so ein Selbstläufer, der offensichtlich solchen modernen Gesellschaften innewohnt, dieses, auch das Fehlens von richtigen, offensichtlichen, richtigen Themen, womit man die Menschen beglücken kann. Und wir sind halt inzwischen in so eine Situation reingeraten, wo auch der Bürger spüren kann, dass das Misstrauen, dass ihm die Politik entgegenbringt, nicht mehr das ist, was zum Beispiel der Staat einer Straftatverdächtigen entgegenbringt, sondern das ist ein generelles Misstrauen. Also man hat ein Auge auf uns. Und das ist natürlich etwas, was mit einer freiheitlichen Gesellschaft schlecht zu vereinbaren ist. Wenn der Staat, dessen Teil ich halt bin und zu dessen Unterhalt ich ja auch nicht unwesentlich beitrage, mir permanent nur Misstrauen entgegenbringt und sozusagen immer an jeder Ecke nur auf Möglichkeiten lauert, mich wegen irgendetwas dranzukriegen.
Dann war ja das Grundgesetz eigentlich mal genau anders umgedacht.
Ja, natürlich. Das sollte ja eine freiheitlich-demokratische Grundordnung sein und die Betonung lag nicht nur auf demokratisch, sondern auch auf freiheitlich. Das heißt, die Freiheit ist immer so weit möglich, wie es nicht zwingend anders geboten ist. Heute ist es ja eher so, dass man die Freiheit einschränkt schon mal aus Zweckmäßigkeitserwägungen. Also man braucht sozusagen immer nur den Aufhänger, sei er auch noch so weit hergeholt, wie möglich, oder so absurd wie möglich, um dann zu sagen, wir schränken die Freiheit ein. Es ist einfach so einfach geworden, Grundrechtseinschränkungen und Freiheitseinschränkungen zu legitimieren, weil die Leute, die sich dann auf diese Freiheitsrechte berufen, ja fast schon, das habe ich so manchmal das Gefühl, nicht nur nicht gehört werden, sondern gleich in eine Querulantenecke gedrängt werden, so nach dem Motorrad.
Die haben ja sicherlich irgendwas vor.
Jaja klar, man ist ja der Böse, wenn man sagt, Moment, ich beharre darauf, dass meine Wohnung unverletzlich ist und dass ich meine Meinung sagen darf und dass ich auch hinfahren kann, wo ich will, ohne dass der Staat kontrolliert, was ich tue, oder dass ich telefonieren kann, mit wem ich will, ohne dass erstmal präventiv unterstellt wird, jede Nummer, die ich wähle, gehört einem Terroristen. Dieses, dieses, das wird einfach ignoriert. Und das ist ja das, was zum Beispiel das Bundesverfassungsgericht auch in der Vorratsdatenweicherungsentscheidung zumindest vorläufig schön gesagt hat. Es weist ja darauf hin, dass die eigentlich schädlichen Auswirkungen gar nicht so die Einschränkungen der Grundrechte selbst sind, sondern dass mit solchen Maßnahmen ja die Angst in den Köpfen geschürt wird. Das heißt also, wenn du weißt, dass der Staat an allen Ecken und Enden lauert und sammelt, um dich wegen etwas dran zu kriegen, dann wirst du dein Verhalten von vornherein so einstellen, dass du deine Freiheitsrechte gar nicht ausübst. Schon aus Angst, du könntest anecken. Nicht, weil du aneckst, sondern du wirst es lassen, etwas zu tun, was du sonst vielleicht tun würdest, weil du Angst hast, ich könnte mich ja hier, wenn auch vielleicht noch 30 Meter entfernt, an eine mögliche Grenze heranrum. Und dadurch entsteht natürlich dann, das steht auch im Urteil drin oder in anderen Urteilen, konformistisches Verhalten. Das heißt also, man hat praktisch die Schere selber im Kopf, weil man nicht anecken will. Und das ist dann eben dieser sozusagen soziologische Effekt von solchen Grundrechtseinschränkungen. Es braucht dann keine Polizei, Macht, die so etwas durchsetzt oder Bußgelder verhängt, weil die Menschen, und das liegt nun mal in der Natur der Menschen, alles daran tun werden, überhaupt nicht anzuecken. Je größer die Angst, die du vor dem Staat haben musst, vor Repressionen ist, desto weniger wirst du überhaupt Freiheitsrechte ausüben. Das sieht man ja auch in derartigen Gesellschaften. Da ist der Konformismus ja das höchste Gut. Ich bin sozusagen nur nicht auffallen, heißt die Methode. Das ist ja auch nichts, was aus der deutschen Geschichte unbekannt wäre, das kann man aber natürlich auch in anderen Ländern unglaublich gut studieren derzeit. Und das Bedauerliche ist eben, dass man offensichtlich in Berlin nichts daraus lernt. Also man kann die Freiheit nicht dadurch retten, indem man die Freiheit abschafft. Das eine mit dem anderen passt nicht zusammen. Und da musste man eben gewisse Grundentscheidungen treffen, nur die werden aus meiner Sicht eben in die falsche Richtung getroffen.
Wie geht es weiter mit der Klage gegen die Vorratsleitensprechung? Das ist ja die Verfassungsklage mit der größten personellen Unterstützungsbreite. Das ist für die Klage selbst nicht relevant, aber natürlich...
Ja gut, das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat ja eine einstfaltige Anordnung erlassen und gesagt, das ist alles problematisch und es darf eben vorläufig nur für schwere Straftaten verwendet werden. Was jetzt übrigens dazu führt, dass zum Beispiel das Bundeskriminalamt in praktisch alle seine Auskunftsersuchen aus Vorratsdaten immer per Textbaustein reinschreibt. Die Anforderung dieser Taten nach 113a Telekommunikationsgesetz ist zur Aufklärung einer schweren Straftat erforderlich. Allerdings nicht erläutert, ich sehe das in zahlreichen Fällen nicht erläutert, wohin diese schwere Straftat besteht. Das heißt also, da wird auch die Regelung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts deutlich umgangen. Man schreibt halt jetzt rein, wir dürfen zum Beispiel schweren Straftaten, schreiben wir halt rein schwere Straftaten.
Ist das auch schlimm?
So viele schwere Straftaten, wie ich in den letzten, seit dieser Entscheidung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts in solchen Fällen auf dem Schreibtisch hatte, da muss ich sagen, da muss ich die schwere Kriminalität, die so etwas rechtfertigt, und das Verfassungsgericht fordert da sehr schwere Kriminalität, da müsste draußen der Notstand herrschen. Also so wird das umgangen, hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht ja gesagt. Und wir müssen jetzt die Hauptsachentscheidung abwarten. Es gibt ja Stellungnahmen, die in eine positive Richtung gehen, die also sagen, dass zum Beispiel, was ich auch gerade erwähnt habe, die Gefahr ist ja nicht die Vorratsdatenspeicherung an sich, sondern das, was in den Köpfen der Menschen stattfindet. Die Menschen werden eben nicht mehr unbefangen telefonieren. Niemand wird mehr bei jemandem anrufen, der einen arabischen Namen hat, um vielleicht mit dem darüber zu reden, warum dessen Sohn das Fahrrad der Tochter kaputt gemacht hat, weil er denkt, mein Gott, wenn das ein islamistischer Terrorist ist, dann ist meine Nummerlage speichert. Weiß man ja nicht. Also das nur mal so als Beispiel zu nennen. Da wird der türkische Nachbar, bei dem wird das Telefon nicht mehr klingeln, weil man Angst hat, kann nicht mit dem sprechen. Der könnte ja ein Terrorist sein. Nur mal ein blödes und einfaches Beispiel zu nennen. Ich bin allerdings skeptisch, glaube nicht, dass die Vorratssattensprechung endgültig scheitern wird. Sondern es wird dann wahrscheinlich bei derart strengen Vorgaben bleiben. Nur wie die dann umgesetzt werden und wie die umgangen werden, habe ich ja gerade schon dargestellt. Dann ist eben die mittelschwere Straftat bzw. die kleine Straftat künftig eine schwere Straftat.
Das heißt, man wird auch noch weiter kriminalisiert, nur um den Anforderungen zu entsprechen.
Natürlich. Das wird ähnlich sein wie bei den Kontenabfragen oder bei der Maut oder bei den Gen-DNA-Proben, die ja heutzutage auch immer schon freiwillig in Anführungsstrichen eingefordert werden. Da werden wir dann auch dazu kommen, dass demnächst oder in absehbarer Zeit, wenn das eben nicht wirklich kippt, was natürlich zu hoffen wäre, die Vorratsdaten quasi routinemäßig abgerufen werden. Das heißt also, da werden die Provider, die Telekom und Ähnliches, sich wegen Betrugsdelikten oder Ladendiebstahl oder Betäubungsmittel, da hat jemand einen Joint verkauft oder so, da werden die Vorratsdaten ihm angeschwollert. Dann kann man nicht hoffen, aber muss ich das nochmal ausmachen, wird halt bei allen dann erstmal durchsucht, die mit den Betreffenden telefoniert haben. Also vielleicht wäre es dann eine gute Idee, immer nur noch vom Festnetzanschluss der Nachbarn zu telefonieren.
Ja, was muss geschehen? Ich meine, das ist alles schwer hinzunehmen. Bisher hatte man immer den Eindruck, es gibt ja dieses schöne Bild mit dem Frosch und der Temperatur. Er springt auf den Herd, dann schreit er laut auf. Aber wenn man die Temperatur schrittweise Grad für Grad hochdreht, dann wird er irgendwann verdampfen, ohne wirklich gemerkt zu haben, dass die Umgebung sich aufgeheizt hat. Man hat manchmal einen ähnlichen Eindruck bei der schrittweisen Weitertreibung dieser ganzen Überwachungspräventionsgesetzgebung. Was kann geschehen? Sehen wir jetzt mit dem Widerstand gegen Zensursolar eine neue Bewegung, die wirklich die Kraft hat, dieser Gesellschaft da einen anderen Schwung zu geben und wo mehr Mut zur Freiheit gefordert wird, bis hin, dass sich das eben auch tatsächlich durchsetzt? Oder sind wir da noch nicht mal da?
Also ich bin nicht so pessimistisch, dass ich sage, das kann nicht gelingen. Ich denke schon, dass sowas gelingen kann. Es muss nicht gelingen. Aber wie ich vorhin schon sagte, für mich ist das beeindruckend eigentlich daran, dass diese Bewegung, die ja zumindest in Berlin schon für Aufsehen und auch gewisse Verängstigungen gesorgt hat, wie man an den Hetzkampagnen, die im Moment gegen das Internet laufen, ja gut sehen kann, dass diese Kampagne angekommen ist und dass diese Kampagne wird ja gespeist aus unterschiedlichsten, auch meist völlig unverdächtigen Quellen. Also auch die Versuche, diese Träger oder die Leute, die da so argumentieren, zu denunzieren, so sehen die Kinderpornoecke zu rücken, oder so sind ja glorreich daneben gegangen. Völlig zurecht. Und diese breite Basis der Leute, die sozusagen mit Sachargumenten etwas erreichen können, die sollte einem ja sehr mutig stimmen. Also das mit Sachargumenten. Das ist ein ganz anderes Niveau der Argumentation. Und deswegen macht mich das sehr mutig, dass sowas überhaupt möglich ist. Und ich denke auch, es ist nicht so, dass da die Energie Alarm wird. Natürlich ist es so, dass wenn jetzt zum Beispiel das Zugangserschwerungsgesetz rechtsrecht wird, das tritt in Kraft, dass dann nicht weiter in dieser Intensität darüber debattiert werden kann. Aber es wird andere Themen geben und es wird auch wieder dann die Fälle geben, wo dann dieses Gesetz wieder in den Mittelpunkt rückt. Ich denke, diese kritischen Stimmen, die sich dann, wenn solche Kulminationsobjekte, also wenn solche Funken sprühen, wo die dann sagen, komm, da erhebe ich jetzt auch meine Stimme, dass es da weiter genug Anlässe dafür geben wird. Das wird eben die Zukunft zeigen, ob die Politik, so wie wir sie heute kennen, also diese Sprechblasenpolitik, die da produziert wird, ob die langfristig in der Lage ist, diesen Trend zur Sachlichkeit und zur informationsorientierten Argumentation, ob die denn wirklich so lange widerstehen kann. Ich bin da sehr zuversichtlich, dass da sicherlich auch positive Einflüsse kommen, wie auch immer die sein werden. Also ich bin auch kein parteipolitisch orientierter Mensch. Ich habe das ja vorhin schon mal erwähnt in unserem Vorgespräch. Ich bin zum Beispiel jemand, der bekennenderweise immer die FDP wählt. Nicht nur, weil ich jetzt Anwalt bin und Freiberufler bin und natürlich ein wirtschaftlich denkender Mensch bin, sondern weil ich den liberalen Gedanken sehr nachvollziehbar finde. Das sehe ich dann auch nicht parteipolitisch, aber es wäre wichtig, dass sozusagen alle diese Parteien, egal wo sie jetzt herkommen, wo sie hingehen, diese Anregungen aufnehmen. Ich muss sagen, was mein politisches Denken angeht, ich tue mich jetzt persönlich schwer damit, z.B. bei der Bundestagswahl, meinem bisherigen Abstimmungsverhalten treu zu bleiben, weil ich eben das Problem habe, nicht so sehr z.B. bei der FDP, aber bei anderen Parteien, dass ich nicht sehe, dass da so eine Abkehrerfolg von dieser Sprechblasenpolitik ist. Also mir wäre persönlich schon sehr geholfen, wenn man das Gefühl hätte, dass Argumente da in Berlin ankommen und nicht nur mit der Arroganz der Macht abgebügelt und ins Lächerliche gezogen wären. Das ist, muss ich sagen, eine sehr schmerzhafte Erfahrung, die man jetzt auch gerade mit der Zugangs-Erschwerungs-Gesetz-Debatte gemacht hat, dass offensichtlich die Einzigen, bei denen es nicht ankommt, diese politischen Entscheidungsträger sind, denn die wiederholen gebetsmütenmühlenartig ihr Credo, obwohl es ja schon in der Sache häufig falsch ist. Also da tue ich mich im Moment sehr schwer, persönlich einfach zu sagen, kannst du in der Tat diese Leute da unterstützen, wenn dann vielleicht auch nur mittelbar zum Beispiel durch so eine schwarz-gelbe Koalition. Obwohl ich grundsätzlich nichts gegen eine schwarz-gelbe Koalition hätte, aber ich habe etwas gegen solche Leute, die zum Beispiel an der Fraktionsspitze sitzen oder so, die einfach einen unerträglich, nicht nur arroganten Eindruck, sondern auch einen intellektuell, muss ich sagen, bescheidenen Eindruck machen, in der Richtung, dass man nicht mehr das Gefühl hat, dass die auf Argumente überhaupt hören können, sondern die scheinen irgendwie wie so ein Zug ins Nirgendwo, um einen bekannten Sänger zu zitieren. Der ist aufs Gleis gesetzt, da bewegt sich nichts mehr. Und diese Leute, die fahren offensichtlich ohne uns ab, habe ich das Gefühl. Und wir bleiben erst mal zurück. Da muss man sagen, dann lasst sie fahren und gucken wir mal, ob vielleicht an ihre Stelle Leute kommen, mit denen man zumindest reden kann. Ich denke, es gehört auch zu einer Demokratie zum Beispiel, dass man zwar argumentiert, aber dass man dann verliert. Gut, die Mehrheit hat halt nun mal das Sagen. Aber dass man argumentiert und trotz guter Argumente nicht mal in eine Diskussion einsteigen kann, die auf einer sachlichen Ebene stattfindet, das ist schon wirklich erschütternd. Und deswegen habe ich im Moment so fast das Gefühl, also für mich persönlich, um da mal ein Bekenntnis abzulegen, ich weiß nicht, wer meine Stimme bekommen wird, aber es kann auch durchaus sein, dass ich mich in die Protestecke verziehe und eben sozusagen zum Bekennenden Nichtwähler werde, einfach weil ich sage, ich kann es nicht vertreten, meine Stimme abzugeben. Deswegen wäre es gut, wenn in Berlin auch Leute dran kommen würden, die einfach auf die Menschen und ihre Argumente hören. Die auch vielleicht sagen, ich kann deine Argumente verstehen, meine Argumente sind diese, und du hast sachlich nicht recht. Ich sehe es eben anders. Aber ich glaube, da muss man einfach die Zeit bringen. Das Wichtigste ist, das macht mir persönlich Mut, um wieder auf das Internet zu kommen, dass jeder sozusagen im Internet eine Stimme hat. Wenn er denn etwas zu sagen hat, dann wird er auch gehört werden. Vielleicht nicht von den Leuten in Berlin, die das Internet ausdrucken und es dann wahrscheinlich doch nicht lesen, aber doch eben von anderen. Da kann jeder eben auch gerade im Internet dazu beitragen, dass die Argumente letztendlich gehört werden und die besseren Argumente hoffentlich gewinnen. Und ich denke, das ist eine vernünftige Perspektive.
Ja, Udo, jetzt würde ich da gar nichts mehr hinterher werfen. Ich denke, das ist auch ein guter Abschluss der Debatte. So haben wir jetzt hier eine ganze Menge Aspekte auch beleuchtet. Ich bedanke mich mal.
Ja, ich bedanke mich auch, dass du in einer Düssel aufgekommen bist.
Ja, sehr gerne. Jetzt gibt es auch gleich noch ein Hörer-Treffen hinterher.
Ja, da wird sich viel Spaß.
Ja, da wird gleich abgeschlossen worden. Ja, jetzt mal an die Hörer. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, wie immer. Vielen Dank auch schon für die Kommentare, die hoffentlich auch fleißig kommen werden auf Blog, Chaosradio, CCC, CDE zu dieser Sendung oder auch zu allen anderen Sendungen, die ihr hört und gerne hört. Ich will auch noch mal kurz hinweisen, wer ihn noch nicht gesehen hat. Udo hat ja auch schon mal einen ganz tollen Vortrag gehalten auf dem 23C3, der sogar zeitweilig wen verdrängt hat. Britney Spears, ne?
Zeitweise Nummer 1 auf Google Video.
Spezifisch über Hausdurchsuchungen, sie haben das Recht zu schweigen. Auch fast schon ein Klassiker jetzt im Kongressprogramm, wo auch eine ganze Menge von diesen Aspekten aufkamen, die wir jetzt nicht näher beleuchtet haben rund um die Hausdurchsuchungen und wie so Freiheitsberaubungen dann auch ganz konkret und realistisch ausschütten, wie man sich dagegen wehren kann. Ja, das war's. Das war Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 129. Und wie ihr euch schon denkt, geht's hier auch bald wieder weiter.